Hey guys, okay, I'm doing an intro right now for SmartLess and I just got back from the market. I just bought a bunch of tapioca. I got nothing except a brand new fresh out of the oven episode of SmartLess for you guys and a couple of morons to help me with it. Stay tuned. Here it comes. SmartLess.
嘿，伙计们，好了，我现在正在为《SmartLess》录制开场白，我刚从市场回来。我买了一堆木薯粉。除了给你们带来一期新鲜出炉的《SmartLess》节目，以及两个帮我录节目的笨蛋之外，我什么都没带。敬请期待。马上就来。《SmartLess》。
SmartLess. SmartLess. Hey, how was the golf vacation? How was your golf trip? It was good. It was really, really good. You really missed one there, Arnett. And that's okay.
《SmartLess》。《SmartLess》。嘿，高尔夫假期怎么样？你的高尔夫之旅如何？挺好的。真的，非常好。阿内特，你这次真是错过了。不过没关系。
That was working. I was working. You were busy providing? I thought you guys went together. I couldn't go. No. I tried. I tried.
那时候我在工作。我在工作。你当时忙着赚钱养家？我以为你们是一起去的。我没能去。不。我试过了。我试过了。
I was with your wife last night, Jason. Sorry? I hung out with your wife last night and your daughter, who I love. Yeah, she's pretty great. So that was a 10-year-old. That's Maple. The 15-year-old Franny had her sweet 16 this weekend. I know.
杰森，昨晚我和你妻子在一起。抱歉？昨晚我和你妻子还有你女儿待在一起，我超爱她。是啊，她真的很棒。那是个10岁的孩子。那是梅普尔。15岁的弗兰妮这个周末刚过了16岁生日。我知道。
I love that. No kidding. She did. And it was... And it's a boyfriend back? Were you back for it? I came back just in time to drive to where she was having it, to kick them all out and lock up.
我喜欢那个。说真的。她确实过了。而且……而且男朋友回来了？你赶回去参加了吗？我刚好赶上开车去她举办派对的地方，把他们都赶走，然后锁门。
And it was great. I was ready to see things that I wasn't ready to see, and I didn't see anything that I was worried about. It was very... I mean, there was like bowls of chips and Oreo cookies laid out on trays. You weren't like sweeping up vape cartridges. Exactly. Obviously, I didn't find any.
而且很棒。我做好了看到一些我不该看到的东西的心理准备，但我并没有看到任何我担心的东西。非常……我是说，桌上有摆好的薯片碗和奥利奥饼干托盘。你不是在清理电子烟弹。没错。显然，我什么都没发现。
But like just sweeping up Oreo cookies and stuff, and where was the party? Was it at Sean's house? There were a lot of Cheetos and cookies and pizzas. It sounds like my 51st birthday. Sean, what was the last big party you threw, Sean, for yourself or just in general? For yourself. I don't know. Years and years and years ago.
但就像只是清理奥利奥饼干之类的东西，派对在哪里？是在肖恩家吗？有很多奇多、饼干和披萨。听起来像我51岁的生日。肖恩，你上次举办的大型派对是什么时候，肖恩，为你自己或者一般的派对？为你自己。我不知道。那是很多很多年前的事了。
Why don't... Why don't... Why don't you treat yourself? Why don't... Well, didn't you guys come to that... Remember that poker party that I had? I don't. I did.
为什么不……为什么不……为什么不犒劳一下自己？为什么不……好吧，你们没来参加那个……还记得我举办的那个扑克派对吗？我不记得了。我记得。
Oh my God. Sean, that was 2004. Yeah. I'm not kidding. I know. It was the fall of 2004 in your backyard. I was there. And you remember the year.
天哪。肖恩，那是2004年的事了。是啊。我没开玩笑。我知道。那是2004年的秋天，在你家后院。我在场。你还记得年份。
You know, we used to play a lot of poker, Will. Why don't we start playing poker again? We talked about it. We've been... We've been threatening. I guess we could do it over here at my house. Why don't we just do it and be fun? Hey, I texted Will yesterday if I could wear these shoes with the suit pants.
你知道，我们以前经常打扑克，威尔。我们为什么不重新开始打扑克呢？我们谈过这件事。我们一直……我们一直都在说。我想我们可以就在我家玩。我们为什么不直接开始呢，会很有趣的？嘿，我昨天给威尔发短信问我能不能穿这双鞋配西裤。
Are you wearing... Now, are you wearing them on the flight too? Yeah. Wait, wait, wait. What do you mean flight? What do you mean suit pants? Oh, right. You're taking off today.
你穿的是……现在，你在飞机上也穿它们吗？是啊。等等，等等，等等。你说的飞机是什么意思？你说的西裤是什么意思？哦，对了。你今天要出发。
He's going to an event. Yeah. Why are you wearing suit pants? And who says suit pants? Aren't they called slacks? Who says slacks? Who says fucking suit pants, bro? Here we go, guys.
他要去参加一个活动。是啊。你为什么要穿西裤？还有谁会说“西裤”？它们不叫休闲裤吗？谁会说休闲裤？谁会说该死的西裤，兄弟？开始了，伙计们。
Here we are. Suit pants versus slacks. We'll be right back. Who says slacks? Let's go back to the socks. Get back up and let's question the socks. Yeah. Aren't there like little faces on that?
我们到了。西裤对决休闲裤。我们马上回来。谁会说休闲裤？让我们回到袜子的话题。站起来，让我们质疑一下这双袜子。是啊。上面是不是有小图案？
Yeah. What are you doing? What is that? You're just checkers. Are they fun? They're hell's tooth. Do you like people who are like, I'm going to wear fun socks today. And I hope then people notice my fun socks and like go, oh man, you must have a real
是啊。你在干什么？那是什么？你只是格子。它们很有趣吗？它们简直是地狱。你喜欢那种会说“我今天想穿有趣的袜子”的人吗？我希望人们注意到我有趣的袜子，然后说：“哦，伙计，你一定很有幽默感，因为我刚注意到你的袜子，这真的显示出你很有幽默感。”你很有个性。哇。你很有个性。看看这袜子。你要去哪儿，肖恩？我今晚有个活动，芝加哥的一个戏剧颁奖典礼。
sense of humor because I just noticed your socks is really shows that you've got a real sense of humor. You got a lot of character. Wow. You've got a lot of character. Look at the socks. Where are you going, Sean? I'm going to have an event tonight, an award ceremony in Chicago for theater.
是今晚的活动，肖恩。今晚的活动。是啊。等等，你几点落地？你是被提名了还是去颁奖？我被提名了，《晚安奥斯卡》。这部剧被提名了，艾米丽·伯格尔演的。我妻子被提名了，编剧也被提名了，道格·赖特和丽莎·彼得森，她是导演，也被提名了。
It is the events tonight, Sean. The events tonight. Yeah. Wait, what time do you land? Are you nominated or are you presenting? I'm nominated and Good Night Oscar. The show is nominated and Emily Bergle plays. My wife is nominated and the writer is nominated, Doug Wright and Lisa Peterson, who directed
太棒了。你没被提名吗？不。我被提名了。真是荣幸。你也要颁奖吗？不。
is nominated. Amazing. Are you not nominated? No. I am nominated. Such an honor. Are you also presenting? No.
你几点到？你要走了。你落地后得直接赶过去。好吧，这听起来计划得很糟糕。你写好获奖感言了吗？我是说，以防万一，我有关于你想感谢谁的想法，我看到肖恩给我看了他的获奖感言副本，他实际上把斯科蒂划掉了。
What time do you get in? You're leaving. You're going to have to land and have to go straight there. Okay. Well, this feels like poor planning. Do you have an acceptance speech written? I mean, just in case I have ideas of just who you want to thank, I saw a look at Sean showed me a copy of his acceptance speech and he actually crossed out Scotty.
他划掉了。他本来写了，然后又划掉了。你们昨晚吵架了吗？是啊，有点。不。我想回到袜子的话题上聊两秒钟。我们别谈斯科蒂吵架的事了。不，我想谈谈朝他扔奥利奥的事。
He'd crossed. He'd had him in and then he crossed it out. Did you guys get in a fight last night? Yeah, a little bit. No. I want to go back to the socks for two seconds. Let's not talk about the Scotty fight. No, I want to talk about the hurl and Oreo at him.
不。不。我觉得袜子的问题是因为我们作为男人，在时尚方面没有太多发挥空间，总是只有西装。高档饮品的选择。你知道我的意思吗？关于衣服。是啊。
No. No. I think the socks thing is because we don't, as guys, don't get a lot of, and as far as fashion goes, a lot of room to play with, like it's always just a suit. Opportunities for high drinks. You know what I mean? With clothes. Yeah.
我以为你会说总是只有连帽衫。但我确实还穿了另一件连帽衫。是啊。我确实喜欢偶尔搭配一下。我没有威尔那样的招数，因为你不怕戴围巾之类的东西。是吗，威尔？或者领巾？
I thought you were going to say it's always just a hoodie. But I do have another hoodie on. Yeah. I do like to accessorize a little bit every once in a while. I don't have the moves that Will does because you're not afraid of a scarf or something like that. Are you Will? Or a cravat?
不。什么是领巾？我不知道。那是上帝，我想。我不知道。你知道，我……看他试图对我们这些不知道的非文化人保持耐心……我能做什么？
No. What's a cravat? I don't know. That's God, I guess. I don't know. You know, I get... See the way he was so like trying to have patience with us Philistines that don't know... What can I do?
我是说，你知道，如果我只是因为我的常用语而被嘲笑。这就是我给你发短信的原因，因为在我们三个中，你可能穿得最好。你确实穿得很好。非常感谢。谢谢你这么说。是啊。不，我真的把这当作一种赞美。我确实对你说过，是的，我是说，我认为那些鞋子还可以。
I mean, you know, I get roasted for it if I just, you know, just for my common parlance. That's why I texted you because out of three of us, you probably dressed the best. You really do. Thank you very much. Thank you for saying that. Yeah. No, I really take that as a compliment. And I did say to you, yes, I mean, I think that those shoes are okay.
是的。但请告诉我是在什么场合。他说这只是个小事。而且是在芝加哥。我说那没问题。是啊。这是件大事。
Yes. But give me the context where it is. And he said it's this thing. It's not a big deal. And it's in Chicago. And I said that it's fine. Yeah. It's a big deal.
你听到的只有芝加哥。那还好。是啊。是在芝加哥。是啊。没问题。在芝加哥没问题。但它们是网球鞋。
All you heard was Chicago. And it's good then. Yeah. It's in Chicago. Yeah. It's fine. It's fine in Chicago. So they're tennis shoes though.
我开玩笑的。不，我所有在芝加哥的朋友，应该指出，都热爱芝加哥。我们在芝加哥玩得很开心。我们三个。我们确实玩得很开心。我们很喜欢那里。但是肖尼，那是你穿西装配的网球鞋吗，还是我看到的整套装备就是这样？
I'm just kidding. No, all my friends in Chicago, it should be noted, love Chicago. We had a great time in Chicago. The three of us did. We did. And we love it. But Shawnee, those are tennis shoes you're wearing with a suit or am I looking at the full outfit right now?
连帽衫是……的一部分吗？不，不。那只是为了坐飞机穿的，但杰森，你对西装配运动鞋而不是正装鞋有什么看法？运动鞋。那不是运动鞋。别再说运动鞋和西裤了。它们就像，你知道……
Is the hoodie part of the... No, no. It's just for the airplane, but what is your opinion, Jason, about like gym shoes with a suit as opposed to like dress shoes? Gym shoes. Those aren't gym shoes. Stop saying gym shoes and suit pants. They're like, you know...
它们是……我穿着它们进门。你管那些叫什么……你管它叫什么？你给有钱人一个承诺……抱歉。我们马上就来，是的。那些就像成人当代鞋。
They're... I wore them on the door. What do you call those... What do you call it? You give like rich guys a prom... Sorry. We'll be right with you, yes. Those are like adult contemporary...
我管那些叫成人当代鞋。我是个有游艇的有钱人。是啊。我是个金融男，我想装酷。所以我妻子给我买了一些汤姆·福特运动鞋。是啊。我就像，嘿，看，我很时髦。我没时间考虑这些。
I call those adult contemporary shoes. I'm a rich guy with a yacht. Yeah. I'm a finance guy and I'm trying to be cool. And so my wife got me some Tom Ford sneakers. Yeah. And I'm like, hey, look, I'm hip. I don't have time to think about it.
我一直担心数字。然后我穿着牛仔裤，穿着这种运动鞋之类的东西。就像，嘿，听着，我穿着这件西装外套，但桌子下面是牛仔裤，我穿着这些该死的酷运动鞋。好吧，要么就做，要么就不做。好了，让我们回到……为什么我对……这么生气？
I'm worried about numbers all the time. And then I'm wearing jeans and I'm wearing these kind of sneakers kind of thing. And it's like, hey, listen, I'm wearing this suit jacket, but then I'm jeans under the desk and I got these fucking cool sneaks. Like, okay, just fucking do it or don't. All right. Let's get back to... Why am I so mad about...
而且杰森，你知道，杰森懂的。你知道我没生气。我只是担心。我知道你没生气。我知道你马上就要很高兴了。今天我们有一位全能的嘉宾。她是演员。她是制片人。
And Jason, you know, Jason gets it. You know I'm not mad. I just get worried. I know you're not. I know you're about to get real pleased. Today we have a guest that is all things. She's an actor. She's a producer.
她是妈妈、模特、奥斯卡奖得主、联合国和平使者，也是我们的朋友。她演过50部电影，但比我们所有人都年轻。让我们看看她今天在《SmartLess》中是如何做到这一切的。我们开始吧，伙计们？请欢迎独一无二的查理兹·塞隆。天哪。是啊。
She's a mom, a model, an Academy Award winner, a United Nations messenger of peace and a friend of ours. She's been in 50 films, but is younger than all of us. Let's find out how she gets it all done today on Smart List. Shall we gang? Please welcome the one and only Charlize Theron. Oh my gosh. Yeah.
就是这样。嗨，查理兹。嘿。早上好。她留着可爱的发型，穿着可爱的毛衣。今天发型很可爱。是啊。这是留长了。
The deal. Hi, Charlize. Hey. Good morning. She's got a cute haircut and a cute sweater on. Cute haircut today. I do. It's a grow out.
我不觉得这是剪的。这是留长了。这是留长了。是啊。这是留长了。而且是深色的，听众们。深色看起来真不错。是啊。
I don't think it's a haircut. It's a grow out. It's a grow out. Yeah. It's a grow out. And it's dark, listener. It looks real good dark. Yeah.
超级可爱。我见过你深色头发吗？我想见过。或者棕色头发。我们管它叫什么？随你喜欢。我是说，我对此并不挑剔。这只是……
It's super cute. Have I ever seen you dark? I think so. Or brunette. What do we call it? Whatever you want. I mean, I'm not that picky about it. It's just...
很冷。很冷。我是说，你是个法庭宝贝。是的，她确实是。她穿了一件我想我在84年穿过的毛衣。她穿起来真好看。谢谢。让我们把那些带回来。
It's cold. It's cold. I mean, you're a court baby. Yes, she did. She's got a sweater on that I think I wore in 84. She wears it real well. Thank you. Let's bring those back.
是的。袜子呢？查理兹，你穿袜子吗？噢，不。让我看看。她来了。没穿袜子。什么都没有。
Yes. What about socks? Charlize, are you a socks? Uh-oh. Let me see. Here she goes. No socks. Nothing.
没穿袜子。看看那个。没穿袜子，没穿鞋。但你有几个纹身。没穿袜子。是啊。肖恩，眼力真快。你注意到了，对吧？
No socks. Look at that. No socks, no shoes. But you got a couple of tats on there. No socks. Yeah. Sean, quick eye there. You noticed, huh?
是啊。快，太快了。我们今天有多少个纹身？我有两个。我很自豪地说。你有腰部纹身？太神奇了。是啊。
Yeah. Fast and fast. How many tattoos do we have today? I have two. I'm proud to say. You have a tramp stamp? That's amazing. Yeah.
就在我后腰上。上面写着“呼吸”。是啊。上面写什么？呼吸。呼吸。所以它起作用了。所以这就像是为你在一起的人准备的公益广告。
It's right on the small of my back. It just says breathe. Yeah. What does it say? Breathe. Breathe. So it's working. So it's like a PSA for whoever you're with.
肖恩，威尔，你们两个有纹身吗？刚杀了肖恩。太搞笑了。当然。肖恩在笑，因为这是一个主意。没有纹身。对。威尔、肖恩没有纹身？
Sean, Will, any tattoos from you two? Just killed Sean. That's hysterical. Sure. Sean's laughing because it's an idea. No tattoos. Right. No tattoos from Will, Sean?
没有。我一直想纹一个。我年轻的时候，想在二头肌上纹一个。我的什么？我的二头肌。然后发生了什么？它消失了。所以你没地方纹了。
No. I've always wanted to get one. When I was young, I wanted to get one on my bicep. My what? My bicep. And then what happened? It went away. So you had no place to put it.
我想纹温德尔·科克。我会成为那种挥手时……它会说话的人。它就像一个……我知道。我现在53岁了，也发生了同样的情况。我不喜欢展示我的纹身。因为两个都是我女孩的名字，在我手臂内侧。
I wanted to get Wendell Cork. I would be one of those when you're waving. It speaks. It's like a... I know. That's what's happening to me now at 53. I don't like to show my tattoos. Because both are on my girl's names on the inside of my arm there.
我没注意到我怎么不说二头肌。然后当我给别人看的时候，当他们问的时候，手臂下面那一小块就开始向他们挥手，这不太好。我的手臂上也有我女孩的中间名。你有吗？真可爱。是啊，就在这儿，炭灰色。但在你的前臂上？
I didn't notice how I don't say bicep. And then when I show it to somebody, when they ask, and then that little bottom part of the arm just starts to wave at them, it's not good. I have my girl's middle names on my arm too. Do you? That's cute. Yeah, in charcoal gray right here. But on your forearm?
在我的前臂上，是的。好吧，让我问你，有纹身的演员，你在拍电影时必须经过化妆来……比如，这很麻烦吗？是啊，你得把它遮住。我拍《黑钱胜地》第一年的时候就是这样，然后我说够了。就说我的角色有纹身吧。谁在乎呢？
On my forearm, yes. Okay, so let me ask you, actors with tattoos, do you have to go through makeup when you're doing a movie to get... Like, is it a pain in the ass to get? Yeah, you've got to get it covered up. I did for the first year of Ozark and then I said enough. Let's just say my guy's got tattoos. Who cares?
你呢，查理兹？我用炭灰色纹的，所以它拍不出来。它超级淡。所以它不会……你不会真的……你注意不到。作为制片人，我发现当它们像这样淡的时候，在数字中间片处理中很容易去掉。
What about you, Charlize? I did this in charcoal gray, so it doesn't really photograph. It's super light. And so it doesn't... You don't really... You don't pick it up. And I have found as a producer that when they're light like this, it's easy to take them out in the DI.
你不需要涂大量的化妆品。如果纹身很淡，几乎更容易直接不管它。但还有那件事……但我认为是从迈克·泰森和《宿醉3》开始的，对吧，你必须获得纹身者的批准或签字。艺术家。艺术家，是的。否则他们以后可以找你麻烦，因为展示了一幅你没买版权的画，或者类似的事情。
You don't have to put a ton of makeup. It's almost easier to just leave it alone if it's a light tattoo. But there's also that thing... But I think it started with Mike Tyson and Hangover 3, right, where you have to get the approval or the sign off of the person who does the tattoo. The artist. The artist, yeah. Or they can see you later for like showing a painting that you haven't bought the license
是啊。真的吗？就像放一首歌。你得付钱。这有点荒谬。还记得以前东西是免费的时候吗？是啊。
for or something like that. Yeah. Really? It's like playing a song. You've got to pay for it. It's kind of absurd. Remember when shit was free? Yeah.
对。还记得人们不为愚蠢的事情感到压力的时候吗？是啊。我记得。哦，我不知道我们都在同时喝酒。抱歉，伙计们。好了。顺便说一句，见到你们真好。
Right. Just remember when people didn't stress about shit that was stupid? Yeah. I do. Oh, I didn't know that we're all drinking at the same time. Sorry, gang. All right. It's nice to see you guys, by the way.
有一段时间了。很久了。是啊。太久了。很多很多年。很多年。我见过你。还记得她上《发展受阻》的时候吗，肖恩？
It's been a while. It's been a long time. Yeah. So long. Many, many years. Many years. I saw you. Remember when she was on Arrested Development, Sean?
你最喜欢的场景是什么？还记得她上《发展受阻》的时候吗？你最喜欢的场景是什么？哦，天哪。她来的时候是我最喜欢的剧集之一。他从来没看过《发展受阻》，查理。这是一个争论点。她扮演了一个叫丽塔的角色。
What was your favorite scene? Remember when she was on Arrested Development? What was your favorite scene? Oh, my God. It's one of my favorite episodes when she came in. He's never seen Arrested, Charlie. It's a point of contention. She played a character named Rita.
丽塔。她是……她是……查理兹，你是……我敢打赌你也不记得了。我不……你是间谍？
Rita. Who was... It was... Was she... Shirley's, were you... I bet you don't even remember either. I don't... You were a spy?
我……或者我们以为你是间谍？你以为你是间谍？你以为我是间谍，是的。因为我有一种非常有趣的英国口音。我听起来很聪明。你有没有……在南非长大，你小时候有口音，后来改掉了，还是怎么回事？
I... Or we thought you were a spy? You thought you were a spy? You thought I was a spy, yes. Because I had a very interesting British accent. I sounded very smart. Did you have a... Growing up in South Africa, did you have an accent as a kid and got rid of it or what happened?
哦，是的。不，我是说，我直到19岁才真正说英语。真的吗？我在一个地区长大。是的。我在一个地区长大，那里……没错，没错。这太糟糕了。
Oh, yeah. No, I mean, I didn't speak English really until I was like 19. Really? I grew up in an area. Yes. I grew up in an area where... That's right, that's right. That's fucking terrible.
等等，等等，等等。来吧，布鲁特。来吧，布鲁特。来吧，布鲁特。我知道南非口音也很难。非常，非常难。总之，是的，我不会说。所以，我把它作为第二语言，但我的邻居没人说英语。
Wait, wait, wait. Come on, Brut. Come on, Brut. Come on, Brut. I know it's a very difficult accent too, South African. Very, very difficult. Anyway, yeah, I didn't speak it. So, I had it as a second language, but nobody in my neighborhood spoke English.
但我去学芭蕾，那里有伦敦皇家学院，所以我们有来自伦敦的老师，他们不会说英语。所以，我真正听到的唯一英语就是这两个英国人对我大喊大叫。哦，那太疯狂了。我参加考试时，甚至不知道自己在考试，因为我听不懂他们在说什么。所以，当我19岁来到这里时，真的就像从零开始学习这门语言，这就是为什么我很容易改掉口音，因为我真的是从头开始学英语。
But I went to ballet and there was the Royal Academy of London and so we had these teachers from London and they couldn't speak English. So, that was the only English I ever really heard was these two Brits yelling at me. Oh, that's so crazy. And I would do exams, not even knowing I was doing exams because I didn't understand what they were saying. So, when I came here at 19, it was really kind of like learning the language and that's why it was easy for me to drop the accent because I was really learning English from scratch.
我认为说英语的南非人更难，因为这是一种根深蒂固的口音，他们试图改掉。我没有那种情况。所以，南非语是一门完全不同的语言。这不是口音的严重程度。这对你来说是新信息。哇。这是一个组合。
I think English-speaking South Africans have a harder time because it's an ingrained accent that they're trying to break. I didn't have that. So, Africans is a completely different language. It's not a severity of accent. This is new information for you. Wow. It is a combination.
大约还有44个人在说它。这绝对是一门垂死的语言。这不是一门很有用的语言。我们知道它是什么的组合吗？是啊，荷兰语。所以，我们几乎整个欧洲都试图进来接管。所以，荷兰语主要是它的基础，然后里面有一些德语，然后我们把它弄得乱七八糟。
There's about 44 people still speaking it. It's definitely a dying language. It's not a very helpful language. Do we know what it is a combination of? Yeah, Dutch. So, we pretty much all of Europe try to come in and take over. So, the Dutch language is predominantly what it's based on and then there's some German in there and then we've bastardized it.
所以，如果我懂荷兰语，但当我讲南非语时，荷兰人会表现得非常傲慢，他们会说，我不知道你在说什么，因为我们把它弄得乱七八糟。我们把它稍微拉平了一点。他们甚至可能说那是一种糟糕透顶的口音，就像你对我说的。等等，我是个白痴。你有没有演过需要说南非口音的角色？我演过，是的。
So, if I understand Dutch, but when I speak Afrikaans, the Dutch person will be like very hoity-toity about it and they'll be like, I don't know what you're saying because we've kind of bastardized it. We've flattened it out a little bit. They might even say that's a terrible, terrible accent like you said to me. Wait, I'm an idiot. Did you ever play a part where you had to do a South African accent? I did, yeah.
你演过？是啊。可能是超级著名的电影，而我是个笨蛋。不，其实不是。那是一部叫《最后的面孔》的电影。好吧。因为我现在可以和你聊九个小时关于《异形：普罗米修斯》，因为它是我的最爱之一。
You did? Yeah. Probably super famous movie and I'm a dumb dumb. No, it's not actually. It was a film called The Last Face. Okay. Because I could talk to you for nine hours about Alien Prometheus right now because it's one of my favorite movies.
我很喜欢它。谢谢，斯科蒂。谢谢你因为某种原因在后台睡着了。看起来门确实是开着的。哦，是狗。是狗。如果那是四肢着地的斯科蒂，她要来听了。噢。
I loved it. Thank you, Scotty. Thank you for sleeping in in the background for some reason. It did look like the door was open. Oh, it's the dog. It's the dog. If it was Scotty on all fours, she's coming to listen. Aw.
好吧。好吧，那么你说你19岁来到这里。查理兹，让我们回到过去。所以，我们在南非。我们决定去……现在，芭蕾舞不是第一位的。是米兰的模特吗？
All right. Well, okay. So, then you said you came here at 19. Charlize, let's go back. So, we're in South Africa. We decide to go to... Now, ballet was not first. Was it modeling in Milan?
嗯，我从小就开始跳舞，然后我去了一所舞蹈艺术学校，那确实是我一生想做的事情。我只是，我爱上了舞蹈，我是说，我真正爱上的是讲故事，但我当时不知道，因为从技术上讲，我从来不是最强的舞者，但当我是《天鹅湖》时，我会在舞台上拼命。所以，我总是能得到工作，因为我能表演。别点头了，肖恩。哦，好吧。
Well, I started dancing when I was really young and then I went to an art school for dance and that's really what I wanted to do with my life. I just, I fell in love with dance and I mean, really what I fell in love with was storytelling, but I didn't know it then because technically I was never the strongest dancer, but when I was Swan Lake, I would fucking die on the stage. And so, I always got work because I could perform. Stop nodding, Sean. Oh, okay.
抱歉。我是说，他在热切地点头。但是的，那是我一生想做的事情，直到我有点做不到了，不得不重新思考我的人生，我妈妈指出，我爱的可能更多是其中的讲故事方面，而不是舞蹈。所以，是她把这一切联系在一起，也许我应该去尝试表演，这就像是最愚蠢、最无知的事情，就像我们什么都不知道。真的吗？
Sorry. I mean, he's eagerly nodding. But yeah, that's what I wanted to do with my life until I kind of couldn't and had to kind of rethink my life and my mom was the one that pointed out that it was maybe more the storytelling aspect of it that I love than the dance. And so, she was the one that kind of put it together that maybe I should go and try acting, which was like the most stupid, ignorant, like we knew nothing. Really?
对如何成为一名演员一无所知。那么，你是怎么做的？一张去好莱坞的单程票。哦，真的吗？她真的给我买了一张去洛杉矶的单程票。哇，不会吧。我下了飞机，无处可去……我是说，我根本没有计划。
Nothing about how you would even go about to be an actor. So, how did you? A one-way ticket to Hollywood. Oh, really? She literally bought me a one-way ticket to Los Angeles. Wow, no way. And I got off the plane and I had nowhere to... I mean, I just had no plan.
我住在农夫女儿酒店，因为出租车……在费尔法克斯？是啊，现在那里很可爱。那时候，它是按小时计费的。是啊。我在沃恩超市对面买了一瓶漂白剂，开始打扫那个浴室，我在那里住了大约六个月。我曾经在那里住过一个小时。
I stayed at the farmer's daughter because the cab... On Fairfax? Yeah, and now it's cute. Back then, it was like by the hour. Yeah. I bought a bottle of bleach right across from the Vaughns and started cleaning that bathroom and I stayed there for like six months. I stayed there for an hour once.
嘿，哦，那你马上就去上表演课了吗？不是马上。我有一个非常奇怪的经历，有点像拉娜·特纳，你知道，苏打水喷泉的故事，当时我在银行试图兑现一张来自纽约的支票，那现在是一张州支票，我兑现不了，这个家伙试图帮我兑现，他最后成了经理。他签下了我，这很奇怪，因为我几乎不会说英语，这说明了我们现在是如何找到演员的一切。
Hey, oh, now did you take acting classes right away? Not right away. I had a very strange experience where kind of like the Lana Turner, you know, soda fountain story where I was at a bank trying to cash a check from New York, which was now a state check and I couldn't cash it and this guy was trying to help me cash it and he ended up being a manager. And he signed me on, which is just weird because I could barely speak English and that tells you everything about how we find our actors these days.
但总之，他告诉了我一个表演班，我开始去那里，尽我所能负担得起，当时大约是一周一次。这很有帮助，因为我对表演一无所知。我什么都不知道。我甚至不知道演员是谁。就像我喜欢汤姆·汉克斯的电影，却不知道他的名字叫汤姆·汉克斯。哦，天哪，里面有太多东西了。他当你的经理多久了，这个家伙？
But anyway, he told me about an acting class and I started going there like what I could afford, which was like once a week at that time. And that was helpful because I knew nothing about acting. I knew nothing. I didn't even know who actors were. Like I love Tom Hanks movies without knowing his name was Tom Hanks. Oh God, there's so much in there. How long was he your manager, this guy?
他当了大约四年我的经理。哇。你真幸运，找到了那个说“嘿，年轻女士，我是经理”的真正经理。就像你找到了一个真正的。我是说，而不是像我的办公室在我的货车里。是啊，每个人都这么说。他们就像，这个家伙，这就是每个人都会发生的事情。就像你会死在沟里。
He was my manager for about four years. Wow. You're so lucky you found the actual manager that says, hey, young lady, I'm a manager. Like you found a real one. I mean, instead of like in my office is in my van. Yeah, everybody said that. They were like, this guy, this is what happens to everybody. Like you're going to end up in a ditch.
然后有人真的认识他，他在我的车里。他的名片在我的车里放了好几个月，他们说，是的，他代理约翰·赫特。我就说，好吧，那是个真正的演员。好吧。所以我给他打了电话。哇。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》由Viori服装支持。
And then somebody actually knew him who was in my car. His card was in my car for like months and they said, yeah, he represents John Hurt. And I was like, well, that's a real actor. Okay. So I called him out. Wow. And we will be right back. SmartLess is supported by Viori clothing.
如果你厌倦了传统的旧运动装备，你一定要看看Viori。这不仅仅是我照着剧本念。这是我真心实意地建议。你知道为什么吗？因为我自己也在用。他们的产品非常通用，几乎可以用于任何活动，无论是徒步、跑步、训练、游泳、瑜伽还是其他什么。但它们也非常适合休闲，或者，你知道，周末和孩子们一起跑来跑去，
If you're tired of traditional old workout gear, you got to check out Viori. This is not just me kind of going along some script. This is me saying, do it for real. And you know why? Because I use it myself. Their product is incredibly versatile and it can be used for just about any activity, whether it's hiking or running or training or swimming or yoga or whatever. But it's also great just for lounging or, you know, running around on the weekend with the kids
或者只是去市场，无论是什么。他们制造的一切都旨在在健身房之外的日常生活中看起来很棒。我有我一直穿的核心短裤。我有长款弹力裤。我有套头拉链衫。所有这些。太棒了。我可以穿着它锻炼。
or just going to the market, whatever it is. Everything they make is designed to look great in everyday life outside the gym. I've got the core short that I wear all the time. I got the long stretchy pants. I've got the pullover zip up thing. All of it. Amazing. I can wear it working out.
我可以穿着它开车送孩子上学。我可以穿着它参加Zoom会议。我想你可以在Zoom会议上穿任何东西。但重点是它超级通用。Viori正在100%抵消他们的碳足迹。他们还在减少和抵消2019年及以后100%的塑料足迹。他们正在为他们的产品利用更好的可持续材料，赋予你最好的生活方式。
I can wear it to drive the kids to school. I can wear it on a Zoom meeting. I guess you could wear anything on a Zoom meeting. But still, the point is it's super versatile. Viori is 100% offsetting their carbon footprint. They are also reducing and offsetting 100% of their plastic footprint from 2019 and beyond. And they're utilizing better sustainable materials for their products, empowering your best act of life.
对你购买的东西以及它们的制造方式感到满意，朋友。Viori是对你幸福的一项投资。对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购买8折优惠。在Viori.com上为自己购买一些地球上最舒适、最通用的服装。那是B-U-O-R-I。你不仅会收到首次购买8折优惠，还可以享受美国境内超过75美元订单的免费送货和免费退货。去Viori.com。
Feel good about the things you buy and also how they're made, friend. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listener, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com. That's B-U-O-R-I. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com.
访问Viori.com购买并发现Viori服装的多功能性。感谢Solo Stove支持本节目。伙计们，外面变冷了，我喜欢这样。终于凉快下来了。而且非常舒适。这是我一年中最喜欢的季节。Solo Stove让它变得更加舒适。秋天有一些特别的东西让我们靠得更近，对吧？
Visit Viori.com to purchase and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Thanks to Solo Stove for supporting the show. Guys, it's getting cold out and I love it. Finally cooling down. And it's so cozy. It's my favorite time of year. And Solo Stove makes it even cozier. Something special about fall that brings us closer together, right?
有了Solo Stove的无烟火炉，创造这些时刻比以往任何时候都容易。享受火炉的所有温暖和舒适，加上便携性、快速设置和清洁。最棒的是，听好了，没有烟。你知道，我有个朋友在他家后院有一个华丽的火炉。每当我们去那里时，聚在一起很有趣，但你最后身上全是烟味。就像有太多的烟，它会钻进你所有的衣服里。你最后闻起来像个烟囱。
And with a smokeless fire pit from Solo Stove, creating those moments is easier than ever. Enjoy all the warmth and comfort of a fire pit plus portability, quick setup and cleaning. And best of all, get this no smoke. You know, I have a friend of mine that has a gorgeous like fire pit in his backyard. And whenever we go over there, it's fun to hang out, but like you end up just smelling like smoke. Like there's so much smoke and it gets all of you closed. You end up smelling like a chimney.
但有了Solo Stove，没有烟。所以我最后闻起来像棉花糖和烤棉花糖。就像没有什么能掩盖那种味道，而且很美味。用Solo Stove火炉升级你的后院，创造值得讲述的时刻，而没有炉边的烟雾。不锈钢结构旨在调节气流并更有效地燃烧。烟很少，你会怀疑怎么会有这么大的火。这是走出户外，花更多时间与家人和朋友在一起的完美催化剂。围绕Solo Stove火炉建立持久的回忆。
But with Solo Stove, there is no smoke. So I end up smelling like cotton candy and s'mores. Like nothing covers up that smell and it's delicious. Upgrade your backyard with a Solo Stove fire pit and create story worthy moments without the fireside fumes. Stainless steel construction designed to regulate airflow and burn more efficiently. So little smoke, you'll wonder how there's so much fire. It's the perfect catalyst for getting outside and spending more time with family and friends. Build lasting memories around a Solo Stove fire pit.
他们非常有信心你会喜欢它。他们提供终身保修和30天免费退货政策。为你最好的户外回忆做好准备，并在Solo Stove秋季活动期间节省大笔费用。此外，在solostove.com使用促销代码smartlist可额外减免10美元。那是solostove.com促销代码smartlist，在秋季活动优惠之上再减10美元。《SmartList》由BetterHelp赞助。所以伙计们，你们不希望生活有一本用户手册吗？我生命中有很多次，特别是在好莱坞这个职业生涯中，比如作为一名演员，
They're so confident you love it. They offer a lifetime warranty and a 30 day free return policy. Prepare for your best outdoor memories yet and save big during the Solo Stove fall event. Plus use promo code smartlist at solo stove.com for an extra 10 bucks off. That's solo stove.com promo code smartlist for $10 off on top of the fall event deals. Smartlist is sponsored by better help. So guys, don't you wish that life came with like a user manual? There's so many times in my life, especially in this career of Hollywood and like being an actor,
你希望有人走过来对你说，嘿，避免这个，避免那个，避免这个人，避免这种性格，拥抱这种性格。了解这种商业生活。就像所有这些你希望有人告诉你的事情，对吧？对我来说，治疗帮助我解决问题。我所做的是写下我想和我的治疗师谈论的任何事情。所以当我见到她时，我已经准备好谈论所有我想谈论的问题，比如自我赋能，或者处理创伤，或者学习应对技巧，
you wish somebody came up to you and was like, hey, avoid this, avoid that, avoid this person, avoid this type of personality, embrace this type of personality. Learn about this business life. Like all of these things you wish somebody would have told you, right? Therapy for me, it helps me just kind of like workout issues. What I do is I write down whatever I want to talk to my therapist about. So when I meet with her, I'm locked and loaded about like all the issues that I want to talk to, like self-empowering myself or dealing with trauma or learning coping skills,
无论是什么问题，我都想和她谈谈。所以我准备好了，这样她就能得到信息并更好地帮助我。这只是我做的一点小事，我从那种风格中受益匪浅。作为世界上最大的治疗服务，BetterHelp已经为300万人匹配了专业许可和经过审查的治疗师，100%在线提供。而且它很实惠。只需填写一份简短的问卷即可匹配治疗师。如果感觉不对，你可以随时轻松切换到新的治疗师。
like whatever the issue is I want to, I want to talk to her about. So I'm prepared so that she can be informed and help me better. It's just a little something I do and it's, I benefited from that kind of style for myself. So as the world's largest therapy service, BetterHelp has matched 3 million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online. Plus it's affordable. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist. If things aren't clicking, you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime.
这再简单不过了。没有候诊室，没有交通，没有无休止地寻找合适的治疗师。在betterhelp.com/smartless了解更多并节省第一个月10%的费用。那是betterhelp, H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartless。现在回到节目。现在当你，当你开始上这些表演课时，你并不真正知道表演是什么，你说这是你的经验，它开始让你感到舒适。你有没有一种感觉，哦，好吧，他们只是给所有我自然而然在做的事情起了一个名字。
It couldn't be simpler. No waiting rooms, no traffic, no endless searching for the right therapist. Learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartless. That's betterhelp, H-E-L-P dot com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Now when you, so when you started going to these acting classes and you didn't really know what acting was, you said it was your experience with it and it's starting to become comfortable to you. Did you have the sense like, oh, well, they just kind of have a name for all these things that I'm just kind of naturally doing anyway.
换句话说，你是否发现了一种非常自然的表演方法，还是你在学习某种技巧，比如按部就班地学习如何表演？还是因为它自然而然地出现在你身上，因为你太擅长了，而且你从来没有真正看到你在表演。看起来这对你来说非常自然。哦，谢谢，杰森。我认为这是一种天赋。对我来说，逃避很容易。就像我认为我在童年时期就利用了它。
In other words, did you find a very natural approach to acting or were you studying sort of like the technique and like going kind of dot to dot about how to act? Or did it just kind of come naturally to you because you're so good at it and you never really see you acting. It seems like it's very natural for you. Oh, thanks, Jason. I think it was a natural ability. It's easy for me to escape. Like I think I used it in my childhood.
这是我生存的一种方式，也是我一直找到慰藉的地方。我把它看作是这个，你知道，我得到的绝佳机会，我可以去完成当时任何材料方面的事情，我可以完全沉浸其中。我喜欢它的那个方面，这对我很简单。但我不知道如何拆解剧本，我甚至不知道如何阅读剧本，我也不一定知道什么是弧线。所以所有这些东西我都必须学习，这就是这个班真正有帮助的地方。因为他们不仅有演员，还有编剧，还有导演。所以我周围都是人，我可以从更高一点的角度看到，而不是那么……
It was a way for me to survive and it's where I've always found solace. And I think of it as this, you know, amazing opportunity that I get to go and do whatever it is at that time, material-wise, that I just get to dive into completely. And I love that aspect of it and that is easy for me. But I didn't know how to break a script down and I didn't even know how to read a script and I didn't know about an arc necessarily. So all of that stuff I had to learn and that's what this class was really helpful for. Because they didn't just have actors, they had writers, they had directors. So I was around people and I could see kind of, you know, from a little bit higher in the ground, not so.
你是否在工作中与演员或导演有过早期的经历，你看到他们和演员一起拆解剧本，或者导演，有没有人对你有真正的帮助影响，比如在工作中而不是在课堂上？哦，是的。我是说，我认为，是的，这个班很有帮助，但最终我是在工作中成为学生的。我是说，我认为这总是最好的工作方式，我回顾我早期所有的经历。我在制片人、导演、编剧和演员那里找到了伟大的导师，他们真的，你知道，真的把我带在身边。我在这里是因为那些人的恩典和那些人的善良，因为我太渴望了。所以，你知道，我想他们被我逗乐了。不过，你有没有和其中一个人有过一个时刻，你现在还记得，你回顾过去，说，
Did you have an early experience with an actor or director on a job where you saw them with the actor maybe breaking down their script or a director sort of, was anybody a real helpful influence for you, like actually at work as opposed to in a class? Oh, yeah. I mean, I think, yes, this class was helpful, but really ultimately I became a student as I was working. I mean, I think that's always the best way to work and I look at all of my experiences early on. I found great mentorship with producers and directors and writers and actors who really, you know, really just took me under my wing. I'm here because of the grace of a lot of those people and kindness of a lot of those people because I was so eager. And so, you know, I think they were entertained by me. Did you have a moment with one of them, though, that you remember now that you kind of go back to and go,
那是一个强大的时刻，我早期合作过的人，导演、编剧、演员？是啊，我是说，我和这个编剧、导演约翰·赫兹菲尔德合作过。这是我拍的第一部电影，他非常善良。你知道，他非常有耐心。我不得不和詹姆斯·斯派德做很多事情，他很可爱，但他是个专业人士，你知道吗？他出现时就准备好摇滚了。我想我当时大约19岁，有几次约翰真的帮我度过了一次可能很艰难的拍摄，因为我太缺乏经验了，你知道吗？
that was a powerful moment, somebody that I worked with, director, writer, actor, early on? Yeah, I mean, I worked with this writer, director, John Hertzfeld. It was my first film that I ever did and he was very kind. You know, he was very patient. I had to do a lot of stuff with James Spader, who's lovely, but like he's a pro, you know? He like shows up and he's ready to rock and roll. And I think I was, you know, like 19 at the time and there were moments where John really kind of like helped me, I think, get through a shoot that could have been tough because I was so inexperienced, you know?
所以我永远感激他。但后来我紧接着和汤姆·汉克斯合作，他真是太可爱了，因为对他来说，一切都是关于快乐。他就像倾注于快乐，快乐，快乐。然后我也有，你知道，相反的经历，比如我喜欢泰勒·哈克福德。我和他拍了一部叫《魔鬼代言人》的电影，还有阿尔·帕西诺和基努·里维斯，那对我来说是一部非常大的电影。他喜欢，他真的鼓励方法派。所以每个人都，你真的没得选。
So I'm grateful to him always. But then I got to work with Tom Hanks right after that and he was just fucking lovely because with him, it was just all about the joy. He was just like lean into the joy, the joy, the joy. And then I also had like, you know, counter experiences like I love Taylor Hackford. I did a film called Devil's Advocate with him with Al Pacino and Keanu Reeves and that was a really big movie for me. And he loves, he really encourages method. And so everybody just, you don't really have a choice.
就像那是他制作的方式，我不知道现在怎么样，但那是当时的情况。所以给特蕾西，那些非娱乐界的人解释一下，什么是方法派？基本上就是24/7让自己沉浸在角色和世界中。所以你永远，永远不会跳出来。你留在里面。你，你的导演会用角色名字叫你。你只是，你一直沉浸在其中。那些人在一起玩超级有趣。
Like that's just kind of like how he makes, I don't know now, but that was back then. So explain for Tracy, the non-entertainment people, what method is? It's basically immersing yourself in the character in the world 24-7. And so you're never, ever out of it. You stay in it. You, your director will call you by the character name. You just, you're kind of immersed in it the whole time. Those people are super fun to hang out with.
是啊。正是如此。所以我在那部电影中意识到，那绝对不是适合我的过程。它有一种让人筋疲力尽的东西。我的生活很悲惨。我不快乐。然后当然你会担心，因为你会想，好吧，如果我不那样做，那么我可能就不会像马龙·白兰度和蒙哥马利·克利夫特那样出色，你读了所有这些传记。
Yeah. That's exactly it. So I realized on that film that that was definitely not a process that was going to work for me. There was something so exhausting about it. My life was miserable. I wasn't happy. And then of course you worry because you're like, well, if I don't do that, then maybe I won't be as good as the Marlon Brandos and the Monty Cliffs and you read all these biographies.
然后我做了一些非方法派的工作，我实际上对工作非常满意。我认为你可以进进出出。是啊。对我来说，有精力去深入挖掘更黑暗的材料，比筋疲力尽更有帮助。当我筋疲力尽时，我有点，我只是退休了。就像我几乎不想进入那个黑暗的房间。我认为当我，所以我把它变成了一种真正的纪律，我认为舞蹈真的在这方面帮助了我。我工作，我把它留在身后，我回家，我捡起我的狗屎，
And then I did some work non-method and I was actually really happy with the work. And I think you could pop in and out. Yeah. For me, having the energy to be able to go a lot further in darker material is way more helpful than being exhausted. When I'm exhausted, I'm a little bit, I'm just retired. Like I almost like don't want to like go into the dark room. And I think when I, so I made it a real discipline, I think dance really helped me with this. I work and I leave it behind and I come home and I pick up my dog shit
我爱我的孩子们，我做意大利面，喝啤酒，生活很美好。好吧，你太该死的好笑了。我希望我希望你多演喜剧。我敢打赌，我敢打赌它们只是没找上你，对吧？我是说，这只是他们没给你发一堆喜剧材料的问题吗？你在和肖恩说话吗？是啊。是啊。
and I love my kids and I make pasta and drink a beer and like life is good. Well, you're so goddamn funny. I wish I wish you do more comedies. I'll bet it's, I bet they just don't come your way, right? I mean, is it just a question of like them not sending you a bunch of comedic stuff? Are you talking to Sean? Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。我们马上就来。就像，你知道，那里就像，好吧，也许你不介意沉浸在，好吧，我想这取决于会是什么样的喜剧角色，但对喜剧使用方法派不会那么痛苦，我想。我认为喜剧是，你知道，这非常像一种品味。就像我认为你爱，你爱喜剧是因为你觉得某些东西很有趣。我想这就是我有时挣扎的地方。
Yeah. We'll be with you in one second. Like, you know, there it's like, well, maybe you wouldn't mind being immersed in, well, I guess it depends on what sort of comedic character it would be, but going method on a comedy would not be as painful, I would, I would suppose. I think comedy is, you know, it's very much like a taste thing. Like I think you love, you love comedy because you find something funny. And I think that's where I struggle sometimes.
是的。我们马上就好。就像，你知道，这就像，嗯，也许你不介意沉浸在，嗯，我想这取决于会是什么样的喜剧角色，但我想，在喜剧中采用体验派演法应该不会那么痛苦。我认为喜剧，你知道，这非常像是一种品味问题。就像我认为你喜欢喜剧是因为你觉得某些东西很有趣。而我认为这正是我有时感到困惑的地方。
You know, there's certain kinds of funny. Yeah. So like for me, the reason why, you know, I had just won the Academy Award for Monster and the first job I did was working with you guys on a rest of development because, Makes sense. To me, I just thought this is such an opportunity to work with these geniuses that I, you know, might never get again. And then they were, the geniuses weren't available, so you came and worked with us.
你知道，有些东西就是好笑。是的。所以对我来说，原因在于，你知道，我刚凭《女魔头》赢得了奥斯卡奖，我做的第一份工作就是和你们一起拍《发展受阻》，因为，这说得通。对我来说，我只是觉得这是一个与这些天才合作的机会，我可能再也不会有这样的机会了。然后他们，那些天才没空，所以你就来和我们一起工作了。
You know, Mitch was amazing and kind of like approaching me and saying, like, do you find this funny? Like let's, if you find this funny, we can figure something out. And that's kind of the comedy that I'm, I don't want to, I don't think I can do comedy that I don't myself find funny. Like I loved working with the point gray guys and Seth Rogen on long shot. Like that was a movie that I really loved. I would make that movie over and over and over again because it was just hands down
你知道，米奇非常棒，他走过来对我说，你觉得这个好笑吗？如果我们觉得好笑，我们可以想出点什么。这就是我所追求的喜剧，我不想，我觉得我无法表演我自己觉得不好笑的喜剧。就像我喜欢和Point Grey的那些家伙以及塞斯·罗根合作《漫长的过程》。那是一部我真的很喜欢的电影。我会一遍又一遍地拍那部电影，因为它绝对是
one of the best experiences, Jonathan Levine kind of shepherded that thing. And everybody was just, I find them very funny. How great is that? Super funny. Yeah. I remember how our minds were blown that you were coming to do the show. Remember, Will, we were just like, wait, what? Yeah.
最好的经历之一，乔纳森·莱文引导了那件事。每个人都，我觉得他们非常有趣。那有多棒？超级有趣。是的。我记得当你来参加节目时，我们有多震惊。还记得吗，威尔，我们当时就像，等等，什么？是的。
Charlie's there and it's coming here. Yeah. Yeah. It was difficult. It was difficult. I was so nervous. I'm going to tell you guys right now. I don't think.
查理兹在那儿，而且要来这儿。是的。是的。这很难。这很难。我当时太紧张了。我现在就告诉你们。我不认为。
It's one of my top five most nervous jobs I've ever done because people don't think of me as funny. So there's this version of like, oh, here comes the dramatic, you know, asshole. That's going to like come and fuck our show up. Yeah. You were just playing this great character. You know, like it wasn't funny to her. You know, that was, that was that band of humor.
这是我做过的最紧张的五份工作之一，因为人们不觉得我有趣。所以有一种说法是，哦，那个戏剧性的，你知道，混蛋来了。她会来搞砸我们的节目。是的。你只是在扮演这个很棒的角色。你知道，对她来说这并不好笑。你知道，那是，那是那种幽默感。
Yeah. And that's, I think that's the humor that I like, but I do feel pressure or something. Like I'm not pressure, but you guys are so good. So I look at you guys and I go, I, I, when I watched you two, and not a whole cast, I have to say it's effortless, but I also know you guys have been on the show for a while and you get into a thing. It's like, there's nothing worse than being the new kid on the show. Like when you show up and it's like.
是的。而且我认为那是我喜欢的幽默，但我确实感到压力什么的。就像不是压力，但你们太棒了。所以我看着你们，我想，我，当我看着你们两个时，而不是整个剧组，我不得不说这看起来毫不费力，但我也知道你们在这个节目里待了一段时间，你们进入了状态。就像，没有什么比成为节目里的新人更糟糕的了。就像当你出现时，就像。
But hopefully you saw how quickly we were all morons and it was just this big dumb family. We were idiots. No, I found you guys very impressive actually. Very impressive. We were very, I remember just being like, what? Just feeling so. I have a question though. You turned into George Michael.
但希望你看到了我们所有人是多么快地变成了傻瓜，这只是一个又大又笨的家庭。我们是白痴。不，我发现你们其实非常令人印象深刻。非常令人印象深刻。我们非常，我记得当时就像，什么？只是感觉太。但我有个问题。你变成了乔治·迈克尔。
I really did. I did. But I, but what's kind of mind blowing to me just hearing your story about coming here at 19 and not speaking English, you just kind of, it's kind of mind blowing that you jumped into these films like with these huge successful people right away where most actors stories are like, I did this commercial and I tried to get a TV show. I couldn't do that. You know, your, your journey was so quick.
我真的变成了。我做到了。但是，但是听到你19岁来到这里且不会说英语的故事，这让我感到非常震惊，你直接就跳进了这些电影，与这些非常成功的人合作，而大多数演员的故事都是，我拍了这个广告，我试着找个电视节目。我做不到。你知道，你的，你的旅程太快了。
No, I did that. I did that. I just skipped over it. I did, I did like Ross dress for less commercials. Oh, okay. Okay. And by that, I mean, I was like an extra in the back, you know, like not, not featured, but no, trust me, I, I was an extra in children of the corn three.
不，我做了。我做了。我只是跳过了它。我做了，我做了像Ross Dress for Less的广告。哦，好吧。好吧。我的意思是，我只是背景里的临时演员，你知道，不是，不是主角，但不，相信我，我，我是《玉米田的小孩3》里的临时演员。
Oh, okay. I, I, no, it was definitely not like, oh, here you go. Here you go. And what about like roommates? Did you have to find other actor room? Like how was the living situation and growing up? Yeah. Yeah.
哦，好吧。我，我，不，绝对不是像，哦，给你。给你。那室友呢？你必须找其他演员室友吗？生活状况和成长过程怎么样？是的。是的。
I mean, I've lived in a loft with two other girls right next to the big five down on the San Vicente. Oh, sure. I lived there for years and it was a, you know, like a one bedroom loft. Just, it was just a room and a bed, you know, coming out of the wall and three of us lived there for, for years. The bathroom was literally right next to the kitchen. And I just, I would look at that toilet from the kitchen sink.
我的意思是，我曾和另外两个女孩住在圣维森特大道上大五金店旁边的一个阁楼里。哦，当然。我在那儿住了好几年，那是一个，你知道，像一居室的阁楼。只是，那只是一个房间和一张床，你知道，从墙上拉出来，我们三个人在那儿住了好几年。浴室就在厨房旁边。我当时就，我会从厨房水槽看着那个马桶。
And I just, to such myself, let this be the motivation, let this be the motivation. We need to live somewhere where our toilet is right next to the kitchen. That was like, that was a huge motivation. You still talk to them. You and Scotty put a toilet in the kitchen just to cut down the commute, just to cut down the commute. You can only put so much sloppy Joe in your face before, you know, you just can't make it.
我当时就对自己说，让这成为动力，让这成为动力。我们需要住在马桶就在厨房旁边的地方。那就像，那是一个巨大的动力。你还和她们联系吗？你和斯科蒂在厨房里放了个马桶只是为了减少通勤，只是为了减少通勤。你不能在脸上塞太多的Sloppy Joe，你知道，你就是吃不下了。
They did the math. I don't know how much time they wasted going back and forth. They sat down at a meeting with their business manager. The truth is so funny sometimes. You're right. Charlie's is still trying to catch a breath. We'll wait. We can trim it all out.
他们算过了。我不知道他们浪费了多少时间来回奔波。他们和他们的商务经理坐下来开会。真相有时太有趣了。你是对的。查理兹还在努力喘口气。我们等等。我们可以把它剪掉。
I'm literally crying. Oh, God. By the way, I've made these guys sloppy Joe's a couple of times now. So maybe that's why. Yeah. Well, I've heard about your Swedish fish. Yeah. I listened to the show.
我真的在哭。哦，天哪。顺便说一句，我已经给这些家伙做过几次Sloppy Joe了。所以也许这就是原因。是的。好吧，我听说过你的瑞典鱼软糖。是的。我听了这个节目。
The plug that a Swedish fish and a piece of sloppy Joe can make. So, um, Shirley's, um, the, the cushy, uh, uh, uh, shooting situation there at 20th century Fox when we were doing arrested is nothing compared to the grueling location of say a Mad Max. Right. I mean, walk us through. Was that, was it as tough as it looked out there doing Mad Max out in the middle of an Australian desert?
瑞典鱼软糖和一块Sloppy Joe能产生的插头。所以，嗯，查理兹，嗯，那个舒适的，嗯，嗯，嗯，我们在拍摄《发展受阻》时在20世纪福克斯的拍摄环境，与比如《疯狂的麦克斯》那种艰苦的外景相比根本不算什么。对吧。我的意思是，带我们了解一下。在澳大利亚沙漠中间拍摄《疯狂的麦克斯》真的像看起来那么艰难吗？
I love that movie. Or was there something really cush just behind camera? No, we shot it in Namibia actually. We were originally going to shoot it in Australia and then. Ask him where Namibia is. Just ask him what side of Africa it's on. Do you know where Namibia is? Over there on the, uh, on the left side.
我喜欢那部电影。还是镜头后面有什么真的很舒适的东西？不，我们实际上是在纳米比亚拍摄的。我们最初打算在澳大利亚拍摄，然后。问问他纳米比亚在哪里。就问他它在非洲的哪一边。你知道纳米比亚在哪里吗？在那边，嗯，左边。
If you're looking at it from the north. You're right. Yeah. Oh, it was a 50-50 chance. Yeah. We'll see the way I confuse you with the left and the north. I was good. It's a, it's a beautiful place, Jason.
如果你从北边看它的话。你是对的。是的。哦，那是50对50的机会。是的。我们看看我把你和左边与北边搞混的方式。我表现不错。那是个美丽的地方，杰森。
Looks insane. Yeah. It's really beautiful. Um, it's where it's the only place where lions and whales meet. Like you'll see lions walk on the beach and eat, um, you know, discarded whales or. No way. Yeah. It's really, it's a magical place.
看起来很疯狂。是的。它真的很美。嗯，它是唯一一个狮子和鲸鱼相遇的地方。就像你会看到狮子在海滩上走，吃，嗯，你知道，被丢弃的鲸鱼或者。不会吧。是的。那真是一个神奇的地方。
There's places called, you know, skeleton coast. And it's like, it's pretty magical. I like that. It has like, like dunes. Like it's just like. Yeah. Sand dunes everywhere. Hundreds of miles of dunes.
有些地方叫，你知道，骷髅海岸。它就像，它相当神奇。我喜欢那个。它有像，像沙丘。就像它只是。是的。到处都是沙丘。几百英里的沙丘。
I mean, the desert is unbelievable. And we went there because the, uh, there was a flood. There was like a rain monsoon that hit Australia right before, as we were in pre-production. And the whole red desert in Australia just ended up being wildflowers. So not very good. Wow. How long of a shoot was that? Like how many months?
我的意思是，沙漠令人难以置信。我们去那里是因为，嗯，那里发生了洪水。就在我们进行前期制作时，澳大利亚下了一场雨季季风。整个澳大利亚的红色沙漠最终都变成了野花。所以不太好。哇。那次拍摄持续了多久？几个月？
Oh, I just want to listen to this. So we had 140 cars that were made in Australia and they had to ship. They put them all on a boat and drove them on the water. What is that? Oh my God. Sales? Sales them all the water all the way to Namibia. Anyway, uh, what were you asking Sean?
哦，我只想听这个。所以我们有140辆在澳大利亚制造的汽车，它们必须运输。他们把它们都装上一艘船，然后在水上驾驶它们。那是什么？哦，我的天哪。帆？把它们都从水上运到纳米比亚。总之，嗯，你在问什么，肖恩？
I was just saying how long, the reason why I don't know how long it is. It was long. Like you have to gear up mentally to be out of your house and your comfort zone because like, uh, when I hear about these like year long shoots, I was like, it's, it's so uproots your life. Obviously we're all doing what we love to do, but it's how are you, how do you cope with that? With the uprooting?
我只是在说多久，我不知道它有多久的原因。它很长。就像你必须在精神上做好准备，离开你的房子和你的舒适区，因为就像，嗯，当我听到这些长达一年的拍摄时，我就想，它，它太让你生活动荡了。显然我们都在做我们喜欢做的事，但它是你，你是怎么应对的？那种动荡？
Jason, you got a question? I just started to think about the list. What would the list look like in order of heartbreak of the things you would be missing, Sean, from home, if you hadn't been shooting in Namibia? Like what, what would be number one? You'd be like, gosh, I just don't know when I'd get my next. It's my bed. It's my bed.
杰森，你有问题吗？我刚开始想那个清单。如果不是在纳米比亚拍摄，肖恩，你会从家里想念的东西按心碎程度排序，清单会是什么样子的？比如，什么，什么会是第一名？你会说，天哪，我真不知道什么时候能得到我的下一个。是我的床。是我的床。
My bed is like, you know, for the sleep, like you want to sleep in your own bed and you want your own couch. Your bed with your fan and what do you like when you sleep? You need a fan running and what else? I need a fan and I need a pillow between my legs. I need two, like a hard and a soft pillow and a thing. Like, you know, there's a cold. And a bowl full of three musketeer minis.
我的床就像，你知道，为了睡觉，就像你想睡在自己的床上，你想要自己的沙发。你的床上有你的风扇，你睡觉时喜欢什么？你需要开着风扇，还有什么？我需要一个风扇，我需要在双腿之间放一个枕头。我需要两个，像一个硬枕头和一个软枕头，还有个东西。就像，你知道，有冷气。还有一碗迷你三剑客巧克力。
Well, I got to wake up in the morning. It gets me going. He's got to be within reach at any. It can't be a king size bed. We're not going to get into Sean's rider right now. The point is, but the point is like, you have your. But it is hard going away. Yeah.
好吧，我得早上醒来。它让我开始工作。他必须随时触手可及。不能是特大号床。我们现在不讨论肖恩的合同要求。重点是，但重点是，就像，你有你的。但离开确实很难。是的。
Leaving to leave. Yeah. It's really hard. I had my first kid. She was, um, she was literally, I think six weeks old and I, I got on a plane with her as a baby. I was a new mom and I was, I mean, I know Namibia a little bit because most of my family, I was from Namibia.
离开去离开。是的。这真的很难。我有我的第一个孩子。她，嗯，她真的，我想才六周大，我带着她坐飞机，她还是个婴儿。我是个新手妈妈，我，我的意思是，我稍微了解一点纳米比亚，因为我的大部分家人，我来自纳米比亚。
Namibia used to be part of South Africa and then in the nineties it became independent. So Namibia was kind of familiar to me, uh, but not that familiar, but I also, I mean, I was, I was crazy. I. And Jason, don't get me started because I know, I know what has to be done for you to go away. Yeah. I would not.
纳米比亚曾经是南非的一部分，然后在九十年代它独立了。所以纳米比亚对我来说有点熟悉，嗯，但没那么熟悉，但我也，我的意思是，我，我疯了。我。还有杰森，别让我开始，因为我知道，我知道为了让你离开必须做些什么。是的。我不会。
I would have passed. I can back you on that. I've been a part of it. It's fucking pathetic. Jason can't even move to the valley. No. Who is fucking kidding? Trust me.
我会拒绝的。我可以支持你。我参与过。这太可悲了。杰森甚至不能搬到山谷去。不。谁在开玩笑？相信我。
We had to shoot in the valley a couple of times and it was rough. It was rough for him. Uh-uh. That is a word. But it was, it was definitely long and it was the same scenery every single day. It wasn't as long as, it went way longer than we thought. So do you have to like mentally prepare like, okay, I'm going to be gone for this long. I need to, this is how it has to go, whatever my, what's in my room.
我们不得不在山谷拍了几次，那很艰难。对他来说很艰难。嗯-嗯。那是个词。但它，它绝对很长，而且每天都是同样的风景。它没那么长，它比我们想的要长得多。所以你是否必须像在精神上准备好，好吧，我要离开这么久。我需要，事情必须这样进行，无论我的，我的房间里有什么。
And like, you know, just so you can make it home because it's going to be your home. I don't need a lot. I just like, I think for me it was important just to know that I was safe because safety is a bit of an issue there. Yeah. And I had a new baby and that what became the biggest issue. You know, I was, it was just me and Jackson in the house and I got broken in like, you know, three in the morning, like five times.
就像，这样你才能回家，因为它将是你的家。我不需要很多。我只是，我想对我来说，知道我是安全的很重要，因为安全在那里是个问题。是的。我有一个刚出生的婴儿，那成了最大的问题。你知道，房子里只有我和杰克逊，我被闯入了，就像，你知道，凌晨三点，就像五次。
That was really scary. Over there. Yeah. Broken into while you're sleeping. Yeah. You can hear, like, where are we staying in like a tent? No, I think of this really nice house. Like they have all these beautiful coastal homes like right on the water and they're
那真的很可怕。在那边。是的。睡觉时被闯入。是的。你能听到，就像，我们住在帐篷里吗？不，我想的是这个非常好的房子。就像他们有所有这些美丽的沿海住宅，就在水边，而且它们
gorgeous. I mean, it puts Malibu to shame, but unfortunately you're bringing in a big production. There's money and you were dealing with people who are living way below poverty. And so it's just, it's, it's a recipe for disaster. So that part of it was my biggest concern. And the people that you would ostensibly hire for security would be. They were kind of part of it. Local.
华丽。我的意思是，它让马里布相形见绌，但不幸的是，你带来了一个大型制作。有钱，而且你在和那些生活在贫困线以下的人打交道。所以它只是，它，它是一场灾难的根源。所以那部分是我最担心的。而你表面上雇来做安保的人会是。他们有点是其中的一部分。当地人。
Yeah. Yeah. They were kind of part of the problem. Yeah. I ended up feeling really safe because if you know the movie, the war boys. The majority of the war boys were actually real military, Australian military that George brought out. And so they.
是的。是的。他们有点是问题的一部分。是的。我最终感到非常安全，因为如果你知道这部电影，战争男孩。大多数战争男孩实际上是乔治带出来的真正的军队，澳大利亚军队。所以他们。
Not to be confused with hot cops, Will. Got it. Got it. Got it. Sorry. But I would text them when I would hear something, I would text them and literally like three minutes later, I would see their flashlights coming in and I just kind of relied on them and they kept me safe the whole movie.
不要和热辣警察混淆，威尔。明白了。明白了。明白了。抱歉。但我听到什么动静时会给他们发短信，我会给他们发短信，真的就像三分钟后，我会看到他们的手电筒照过来，我就有点依赖他们，他们整部电影都保护了我的安全。
Right. Oh my God. And then you wake up. I mean, that was a very physically like grueling part for you as well. Yeah. Yeah. Right. It was actually cold.
对。哦，我的天哪。然后你醒来。我的意思是，那对你来说也是一个身体上非常艰苦的部分。是的。是的。对。实际上很冷。
Really cold. It looks hot. Yeah. It was freezing. We had a lot of cases of hypothermia that, especially the young girls who only wear like bandages. Yeah. Like a lot of them got hypothermia. I don't know.
真的很冷。看起来很热。是的。冷得要命。我们有很多体温过低的病例，尤其是那些只穿绷带的年轻女孩。是的。她们很多人体温过低。我不知道。
I was freezing just because when you don't have hair on your head, you forget. Like it's like a heat releaser. So it was really cold actually. Now I'd rather freeze than sweat. Absolutely. So like that sounds good to me. Yeah. Absolutely.
我冷得要命，只是因为当你头上没有头发时，你会忘记。就像它是一个热量释放器。所以实际上真的很冷。现在我宁愿冻着也不愿出汗。绝对。所以就像那听起来对我来说不错。是的。绝对。
Yeah. It's 110. I like it when I'm, when I have to do like action, I like colder better. Right. Yeah. Yeah. Right. For sure.
是的。110度。我喜欢当我，当我必须做像动作戏时，我更喜欢冷一点。对吧。是的。是的。对。肯定的。
It's harder for me to have a lot of, a ton of energy to like do fight scenes when it's like I just did this movie in Rome and it was one of the hottest summers. It was 115 degrees every single day. And I had to do these fight scenes out in like these Roman streets and I, it was just like you couldn't keep fluid in your body. And were you wearing clothes and playing a character where you weren't supposed to be sweating? Like that, that's, that's when the heat is dry.
对我来说，当天气很热时，要有很多，大量的精力去做打斗场面很难，就像我刚在罗马拍了这部电影，那是夏天最热的时候之一。每天都是115度。我不得不在那些罗马街道上做这些打斗场面，我，它就像你无法保持体内的水分。而且你穿着衣服，扮演一个不应该出汗的角色吗？就像那样，那是，那是当热量干燥的时候。
Yeah. I mean, I, after a while I'm just like, I, that's like the last thing I'm fucking thinking about. I'm just the whole cramping. Yeah. I'm like, that's like the last of my, I'm like, can I just be able to walk? Like your feet start cramping because you just have no fluid in your body. So yeah, I definitely prefer a little colder. So many action films.
是的。我的意思是，过了一会儿我只是觉得，我，那是最后一件我他妈想的事情。我只是整个抽筋。是的。我就像，那是最后一件我的，我就像，我能走路吗？就像你的脚开始抽筋，因为你体内根本没有水分。所以是的，我绝对更喜欢冷一点。这么多动作片。
I mean, are you, you must have been injured beyond any ability to recuperate and keep schedules going forward? I mean, are there any stories of, of you just saying, all right, that's it. We're down for a couple of weeks. No. With an injury. No. I don't know if it's stupidity or if it's just a high, I have a high, maybe a high tolerance
我的意思是，你，你一定受过伤，超出了任何恢复能力并继续保持日程安排？我的意思是，有没有什么故事是你只是说，好吧，就这样。我们停工几周。不。受伤了。不。我不知道是愚蠢还是只是高，我有一个高，也许是一个高耐受力
for pain, but I, I, on the first all guard, I tore this, the tendon off this bone on my thumb. It got stuck in a, in a, in a guy's, like his, his, yeah. And it just, he moved and he ripped my whole thumb backwards. Oh my God. And I, I mean, it was really painful. And I just kind of, you know, when you have an injury, you just kind of don't use it so much.
对疼痛，但我，我在第一部《守卫》中，我把大拇指上的肌腱从骨头上撕下来了。它卡在了一个，在一个家伙的，就像他的，他的，是的。然后他动了一下，把我的整个大拇指往后扯。哦，我的天哪。而且我，我的意思是，真的很痛。我只是有点，你知道，当你受伤时，你只是有点不太用它。
And so I just didn't use it so much, but I had to do like three weeks of a big action sequence on a horse where I was riding with that hand and fighting with the right. And so I was just in denial. And then I came back and, and had surgery. It was, it was just floating. There was like nothing holding it. And I just finished the second one. Now I just came back, uh, like 10 days ago and I just had shoulder surgery to two days
所以我只是不太用它，但我必须在马背上做三周的大动作戏，我用那只手骑马，用右手打斗。所以我只是在否认。然后我回来，做了手术。它，它只是漂浮着。什么都没有支撑它。我刚拍完第二部。现在我刚回来，嗯，大约10天前，我刚做了肩膀手术，两天前。
ago. No worries. You're not, you're not, you're not old, but you're not 15. No, I'm not, but you know, I recover really fast and, and I, my body is in great shape. These are all just like superficial injuries. Like I actually, my shoulder is actually great. My knees are great. How's your stunt double doing?
没关系。你不是，你不是，你不是老了，但你不是15岁。不，我不是，但你知道，我恢复得很快，而且，我的身体状况很好。这些都只是像表面伤。就像我实际上，我的肩膀其实很好。我的膝盖很好。你的替身怎么样？
It's little, huh? How's your stunt double doing? Yeah. I mean, I bet you have the same one for years. Listen, she does, she does, she does like, you know, I'm not going to do stupid hard falls down a staircase or like, you know, falling from a second. I don't do stuff like that. But she is, is she still okay?
很小，嗯？你的替身怎么样？是的。我的意思是，我敢打赌你多年来一直用同一个。听着，她做，她做，她做像，你知道，我不会做从楼梯上摔下来的愚蠢重摔，或者像，你知道，从二楼摔下来。我不做那种事。但她是，她还好吗？
Yeah. She's, she's fucking 24. I mean, nothing hurts at 24. What about Liam Neeson's stunt double? He must be all banged up. My God. That poor bastard. It's fun to do this stuff.
是的。她，她他妈24岁。我的意思是，24岁时什么都不疼。连姆·尼森的替身怎么样？他一定浑身是伤。天哪。那个可怜的混蛋。做这些事很有趣。
I like it. I really love it. You need a nice sitcom. You need a nice sitcom. No, I don't know. I don't, I think I'm, I'm not quite ready. I think like another, maybe in another 10 years. Yeah.
我喜欢它。我真的很喜欢它。你需要一部好的情景喜剧。你需要一部好的情景喜剧。不，我不知道。我不，我想我，我还没准备好。我想像再过，也许再过10年。是的。
There's something so fucking invigorating about hanging off the side of a helicopter. It's amazing. But what about, didn't, you kind of got injured when you put on all that weight for, uh, Sully, right? I had more injuries on that movie. Yes. Just from gaining weight. I, I had to herniated a disc at my lower back because I just,
挂在直升机侧面有什么他妈的令人振奋的东西。太棒了。但是，难道你没有，你在为《萨利机长》增重时受伤了吗，对吧？我在那部电影里受了更多的伤。是的。只是因为增重。我，我腰椎间盘突出，因为我只是，
We had that happen. Well, I gained like 50 pounds and then I had to wear a pregnancy belly that Jason Reitman, the director thought would be a good idea to make the actual size, the weight of the actual, so weighed like another 40 pounds. And then he put me in a fitting and I had to put shoes on over and over and just, you know, from bending and putting on shoes. I herniated a disc in my lower back and that's been the worst injury I've ever had. Wow.
我们发生过那种事。好吧，我增重了大约50磅，然后我不得不穿一个怀孕的肚子，导演杰森·雷特曼认为把实际尺寸做成实际重量是个好主意，所以重了大约40磅。然后他让我试穿，我不得不一遍又一遍地穿鞋，你知道，因为弯腰和穿鞋。我腰椎间盘突出，那是我受过的最严重的伤。哇。
We'll be right back. We get support from Thuma. Your bedroom deserves a refresh, right? And now is the perfect time to elevate the most important room in your home with Thuma. Introducing the bed by Thuma, handcrafted from eco-friendly, high quality upcycled wood. You'll find beautiful, unique variations in the natural grain. The minimalist design featuring Japanese joinery helps elevate any space. It's super supportive for your mattress, breathable and made to naturally minimize noise
我们马上回来。我们得到了Thuma的支持。你的卧室值得焕然一新，对吧？现在是提升家中最重要的房间的最佳时机，用Thuma。介绍Thuma的床，由环保、高质量的升级再造木材手工制作。你会发现天然纹理中美丽、独特的差异。采用日本细木工技术的极简设计有助于提升任何空间。它对你的床垫非常有支撑力，透气，并且旨在自然地减少噪音
and create space. The perfect platform bed frame just got better. You can now customize the bed by choosing between their original pillow board or their new solid wood headboard. Made for how you live, the bed by Thuma is backed with a lifetime warranty, ships right to your door in three easy to maneuver boxes and takes about five-ish minutes to assemble with no tools required. You can easily build it yourself.
并创造空间。完美的平台床架变得更好了。你现在可以通过选择他们原来的枕头靠背或他们新的实木床头板来定制床。为你的生活方式而生，Thuma的床有终身保修，直接运送到你家门口，装在三个易于移动的盒子里，大约五分钟左右即可组装，无需工具。你可以轻松地自己组装。
So like I got one, I'm setting it up in my room because you know Scott and I sleep in separate rooms because of the snoring. We both snore. We wouldn't be together if we slept in the same bed. It would just be a nightmare. So he walks in, he sees me setting mine up and he's like, do you need help? I'm like, no, look at me. Look at this body.
所以就像我买了一个，我正在我的房间里安装它，因为你知道斯科特和我因为打呼噜分房睡。我们都打呼噜。如果我们睡在同一张床上，我们就不会在一起了。那简直是一场噩梦。所以他走进来，看到我正在安装我的，他就像，你需要帮忙吗？我就像，不，看看我。看看这个身体。
Look at how I'm doing this all by myself. Look at my fat stomach hanging over the side of this gorgeous walnut finish. I mean, clearly I don't need anybody's help. And then I was like, can you get this other side? No, I did it all by myself. It was like so easy and it did. I actually did it under five minutes because I'm fast. But anyway, create that feeling of checking into your favorite boutique hotel suite, but
看看我是怎么独自完成这一切的。看看我那挂在胡桃木饰面边缘的肥肚子。我的意思是，显然我不需要任何人的帮助。然后我就像，你能帮我弄另一边吗？不，我完全是自己做的。它就像太容易了，而且确实。我实际上在五分钟内完成了，因为我很快。总之，创造那种入住你最喜欢的精品酒店套房的感觉，但
at home with The Bed by Thuma. And now go to Thuma.co slash smartlist to receive a $25 credit towards your purchase of The Bed plus free shipping in the continental U.S. Go to Thuma.co slash smartlist. That's Thuma.co slash smartlist for a $25 credit. Hey, smartlist listener. We're brought to you in part by G4. G4 is a crowd pleaser.
在家用Thuma的床。现在去Thuma.co/smartlist，在购买床时获得25美元的抵用金，外加美国大陆免费送货。去Thuma.co/smartlist。那是Thuma.co/smartlist，获得25美元抵用金。嘿，Smartless听众。我们部分由G4赞助。G4是一个大众喜爱的品牌。
They've got men's and women's apparel footwear and golf accessories. And right now G4 has teed up some new limited edition releases just in time for my spouse them for me for the holidays. Plus get ahead of the gifting game and enjoy complimentary shipping on your order. Looking for a big showstopper gift? Try a personalized golf bag. Or maybe you need a last minute stocking stuffer, a new colorful golf glove or a putter cover as sure to please check out their holiday gift guide for the avid golfer or golf fan in your life.
他们有男装和女装、鞋类和高尔夫配件。现在G4推出了一些新的限量版产品，正好赶上我的配偶为我准备的节日礼物。此外，在送礼游戏中领先一步，享受订单免费送货。寻找一份重磅礼物？试试个性化高尔夫球包。或者也许你需要一个最后一分钟的圣诞袜礼物，一个新的彩色高尔夫手套或推杆套，一定会让人满意，看看他们的节日礼物指南，为你的高尔夫爱好者或高尔夫球迷。
Need some more wrecks? The classic Gallivant or golf shoe style is a crowd pleaser with optimal traction. And their MG4X2s are great for on and off the course, making them ideal for the casual golfer. So it's really, really cool. And I can't wait to put it on my body. Check out their site and order soon to ensure your gifts are delivered before the holidays by going to GFORE.com slash smartlist to get 10% off your first order today. One more time.
需要更多推荐？经典的Gallivant高尔夫鞋款式是大众喜爱的，具有最佳的抓地力。他们的MG4X2s非常适合球场内外，使它们成为休闲高尔夫球手的理想选择。所以它真的，真的很酷。我迫不及待地想把它穿在身上。查看他们的网站并尽快订购，以确保你的礼物在节日前送达，访问GFORE.com/smartlist，今天你的第一笔订单可享10%的折扣。再说一次。
That's G4.com slash smartlist. Smartlist is supported by Audible. You don't ride an elevator for the music, do you? Or pick an airline for the movies. So when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose Audible. Get it? It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke, Carrie Washington and Kevin Hart. It's home to epic adventures, chilling mysteries and can't miss comedies.
那是G4.com/smartlist。Smartless由Audible支持。你不会为了音乐坐电梯，对吧？或者为了电影选择航空公司。所以当谈到音频娱乐时，选择Audible是有道理的。明白了吗？它是伊桑·霍克、凯丽·华盛顿和凯文·哈特等大明星讲述故事的家园。它是史诗冒险、令人毛骨悚然的悬疑和不可错过的喜剧的家园。
Audible is the home of storytelling. Let your imagination soar with audiobooks, podcasts and originals. So everybody knows in Los Angeles, you drive a lot, right? So you spend like, I don't know, half your life it feels like inside your car. So what I do is I stick on Audible and I put on like one of those like true crime things or better yet, a sci-fi thing. And I completely lose myself in the imagination while focusing on the road. But I lose myself in the stories. You know what I'm saying?
Audible是讲故事的家园。让你的想象力在有声读物、播客和原创作品中翱翔。所以每个人都知道在洛杉矶，你开车很多，对吧？所以你花，我不知道，感觉你生命的一半都在车里。所以我做的是，我打开Audible，我放上像那种真实犯罪的东西，或者更好的是，科幻的东西。我在专注于道路的同时完全沉浸在想象中。但我沉浸在故事中。你知道我在说什么吗？
Like the sci-fi, like how deep it goes into some of those shows is like really, really, really cool. I really get off on that stuff. Audible is the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app. Find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Audible has an incredible selection of audiobooks across every genre from bestsellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business and more. As an Audible member, you can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest bestsellers and new releases.
就像科幻，就像它深入到那些节目中的程度，真的，真的，真的很酷。我真的很喜欢那些东西。Audible是讲故事的家园，将你所有的音频娱乐集中在一个应用程序中。找到你所爱的最好的东西或发现一些新的东西。Audible在每个流派中都有令人难以置信的有声读物选择，从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑和惊悚、励志、健康、商业等等。作为Audible会员，你可以每月从他们的整个目录中选择一个标题保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。
Members also get full access to a growing selection of included audiobooks, Audible originals and podcasts. You can download or stream our included titles all you want. One of the things I'm listening to and loving is Stephen King's fairy tale. Somebody asked him like what he wanted to write during the pandemic, like what he wanted to do the most and this was it. And I was like, oh my God, I got to check this out. It's fantastic. Let Audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try it for free for 30 days.
会员还可以完全访问越来越多的包含的有声读物、Audible原创作品和播客。你可以随意下载或流式传输我们包含的标题。我正在听并喜欢的一件事是斯蒂芬·金的《童话》。有人问他疫情期间想写什么，就像他最想做什么，这就是了。我当时就想，哦，我的天哪，我得看看这个。太棒了。让Audible帮助你发现新的方式来欢笑、获得灵感或娱乐。新会员可以免费试用30天。
Visit Audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500. That's Audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days. Audible.com slash smartlist. All right. Back to the show. Can I tell you something? This is a true story. Okay.
访问Audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500。那是Audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500，免费试用Audible 30天。Audible.com/smartlist。好的。回到节目。我能告诉你一件事吗？这是一个真实的故事。好的。
First of all. We're going to listen harder. Thanks for stopping lying. Go ahead, John. This is a true story. I was sitting there watching because you have this unbelievable ability to like we spoke about earlier to lose yourself into every character you play. It's very rare that, you know, there's Philip Seymour Hoffman who was just like transformative. There's you who's always transformative.
首先。我们要更认真地听。谢谢你停止撒谎。继续，约翰。这是一个真实的故事。我坐在那里看着，因为你有这种令人难以置信的能力，就像我们之前谈到的，让自己沉浸在你扮演的每一个角色中。很少有，你知道，有菲利普·塞默·霍夫曼，他就像变形一样。有你，总是变形。
It's just an incredible feat. So I'm sitting there with Scotty, my husband watching bombshell. I swear to God, I'm not making this up. And like half hour, 40 minutes in, I'm like, where the fuck is Charlie Stern? I thought she was in this movie. And he's like, what, you idiot? That's her. And I'm like, as Megan Kelly, I was blown away.
这真是一个不可思议的壮举。所以我坐在那里和我的丈夫斯科蒂一起看《爆炸新闻》。我发誓，我不是编的。半小时，40分钟后，我就像，查理兹·塞隆他妈的在哪儿？我以为她在这部电影里。他就像，什么，你这个白痴？那就是她。我就像，作为梅根·凯利，我被震撼了。
I mean, you look like her. You sound like her. It was so funny, you guys. I think it's like amazing. I don't fuck them. I'm enjoying this moment, Charlie. I'm just looking at your screen right now. It's just me and you.
我的意思是，你看起来像她。你听起来像她。这太有趣了，你们。我觉得这太棒了。我不他妈管他们。我正在享受这一刻，查理兹。我现在只是看着你的屏幕。只有我和你。
And that's all I wanted to say. I don't have a question. Like I really truly was like, I thought Charlize was in this movie. That's nice. That's her. It is pretty impressive. I mean, it was mind blowing. What about this new thing, a school for good and evil?
这就是我想说的。我没有问题。就像我真的，真的就像，我以为查理兹在这部电影里。那很好。那就是她。这确实令人印象深刻。我的意思是，这太令人震惊了。那这个新东西，《善恶学校》呢？
What are you doing in that? And what, why'd you want to do it? What, what, what about it? Was it Paul Feig? Cause he's a good dude. Yeah. He did our, he did a couple of episodes of our aggressive element. Yeah.
你在那里面做什么？还有什么，你为什么想做它？什么，关于它？是保罗·费格吗？因为他是个好人。是的。他做了我们的，他做了我们《发展受阻》的几集。是的。
Yeah. He's such an amazing guy. I also just, you know, I have two young kids now, seven and 10. And they're going to have to be like, at least, you know, 52 to see any of my work. So there is a level of wanting to make stuff for them because they, they love this world, this kind of fantasy world. And it was also, oh, fuck man. It was like towards the end of our lockdown and I was going star crazy.
是的。他真是个了不起的人。我也只是，你知道，我现在有两个年幼的孩子，七岁和十岁。他们必须，你知道，至少52岁才能看到我的任何作品。所以有一种想为他们制作东西的愿望，因为他们，他们喜欢这个世界，这种奇幻世界。而且它也，哦，他妈的伙计。那是在我们封锁快结束的时候，我快疯了。
I was homeschooling the two of them. And I obviously couldn't take a job because I didn't want to move them. You know, it just wasn't the right time to move a whole family somewhere. So it was a two week job up in Belfast. And they got me back in 14 days and my mom took the kids. And so that was nice too. But yeah, mostly I did it for them. I, I want, you know, there's something, I don't know, there's something about,
我在家教他们两个。我显然不能接工作，因为我不想搬动他们。你知道，搬动整个家庭去某个地方并不是合适的时机。所以那是在贝尔法斯特的两周工作。他们在14天内把我送了回来，我妈妈带着孩子们。所以那也很好。但是的，我主要是为了他们做的。我，我想要，你知道，有些东西，我不知道，有些东西关于，
you know, kids that no matter who you are, you want to impress them. Like they're not impressed by Megan Kelly. Right. And it's also proof of like, well, this is, you know, mom is busy, but I swear I'm busy doing stuff. I swear it like, here's something you can see. It's proof. Well, they see the posters when we drive to the bus.
你知道，孩子，无论你是谁，你都想给他们留下深刻印象。就像他们对梅根·凯利印象不深。对吧。而且这也是证明，就像，好吧，这是，你知道，妈妈很忙，但我发誓我忙着做事情。我发誓它，这里有一些你可以看到的东西。这是证明。好吧，他们开车去坐校车时会看到海报。
They never see the movies, right? But they always see the posters and they spend time on set and things like that. So they think they know what the movie is. And it's really funny when they're like, they see the poster and they just go, well, I don't know if that is the movie that I saw you make. All right. How do you manage to do all of this work and still be such a great mom? Because I know you put an incredible time and focus to being an incredible mother.
他们从不看电影，对吧？但他们总是看到海报，他们花时间在片场之类的地方。所以他们认为他们知道电影是什么。当他们看到海报时，他们只是说，好吧，我不知道那是不是我看到你拍的那部电影，这真的很有趣。好的。你是怎么设法做所有这些工作，同时还是一个伟大的妈妈？因为我知道你投入了不可思议的时间和专注来成为一个不可思议的母亲。
And I know that you've got incredible help from your mother who is an incredible woman. But like, but as I said in the intro, 50 films, like it takes a few months to do a movie, especially when you're the lead, like you always are. Like the math doesn't even work out. I don't know how you've gotten all that done and still been, you know. Well, I've been producing for, you know, close to two decades now. And I think that's really helped just taking some agency and making my own schedule. And so I really don't make anything like, I don't make any big movies unless I, you know,
而且我知道你从你妈妈那里得到了不可思议的帮助，她是一个不可思议的女人。但是像，正如我在介绍中所说的，50部电影，拍一部电影需要几个月，尤其是当你像你总是那样是主角时。就像数学根本算不过来。我不知道你是怎么完成所有这些，同时还是，你知道。好吧，我已经制作了，你知道，快二十年了。而且我认为这真的很有帮助，只是采取一些主动权并制定我自己的时间表。所以我真的不拍任何东西，除非我，你知道，
I push it into the summer where I can take my whole family. Like we all went to Rome for four months and, but, you know, I get my kids back for school, but you're right. I can't do it without my mom. And I'm always very vocal and acknowledging that I am co-parenting with her. So that's kind of unusual for people to hear, but that is the truth. She really is, is very much a co-parent. I got that.
我把它推到夏天，我可以带上我的整个家庭。就像我们都去了罗马四个月，但是，你知道，我让我的孩子回来上学，但你是对的。没有我妈妈我做不到。而且我总是非常直言不讳地承认我正在和她共同抚养。所以人们听到这个有点不寻常，但那是事实。她确实，确实在很大程度上是共同抚养者。我明白了。
Yeah, it's amazing. I'm so lucky. I'm so lucky. How much of, how much, because your mom's been there obviously the whole time and, and you are so close to her. How much do you talk to her about what choices you make as a, you know, sort of artistically as a producer or as a, as an actor? Do you have a relationship like that at all?
是的，这太棒了。我太幸运了。我太幸运了。多少，多少，因为你妈妈显然一直都在那里，而且你和她那么亲近。你和她谈论你作为，你知道，某种艺术上作为制片人或作为演员所做的选择有多少？你有那样的关系吗？
Do you go like, Hey, I'm thinking about doing this thing. What do you think? Do you take, do you sound stuff off of her in that way too or no? So when I started, she was definitely, she was way more opinionated. I mean, she definitely, she's, she's very direct. Jason, you've met her. She's very funny. She's very direct.
你会去说，嘿，我在考虑做这件事。你觉得怎么样？你也会那样和她商量吗，还是不？所以当我开始时，她绝对，她更有主见。我的意思是，她绝对，她，她非常直接。杰森，你见过她。她非常有趣。她非常直接。
She's kind of, she's a broad. She's very, very brassy and loud and she loves to swear and she's just very honest. So in the beginning, when I started, there was a lot of like wanting her approval, but she would go and see some of my movies and just be like, that's a piece of shit. Before you even had the theater. Yeah. And I was like, you should come out and you could just tell on her face. She was like, that is not good.
她有点，她是个泼辣的女人。她非常，非常粗鲁和吵闹，她喜欢骂人，她只是非常诚实。所以一开始，当我开始时，有很多像想要她认可的东西，但她会去看我的一些电影，然后只是说，那是一坨屎。在你甚至还没到剧院之前。是的。我当时就像，你应该出来，你可以从她的脸上看出来。她就像，那不好。
But I appreciate it so much from her. It's kind of our relationship. I remember as a dancer too, when I was little, like I would have a competition or something. She was never the parent that would sugarcoat it. She wasn't like abusive about it, but she was very honest. I knew that when she said something was good, I was like, fuck, that was, then that was really good. Yeah. You know, like I really believe that more than the negative stuff.
但我非常感谢她。这是我们的关系。我还记得小时候作为舞者，就像我会参加比赛什么的。她从来不是那种会粉饰太平的父母。她对此并不像虐待，但她非常诚实。我知道当她说某事很好时，我当时就像，他妈的，那，那真的很好。是的。你知道，就像我真的相信那个，而不是负面的东西。
It becomes like a real barometer for you. Exactly. I can really trust her. So it's not so much, I mean, I tell her obviously because she's part of it. I have to like clear her tennis and golf schedule out here so that she can like, you know, pack up and move with me. But yeah, she likes a lot of stuff. She loves, she loves like the long shots. She likes those kind of movies way more.
它变成了你真正的晴雨表。完全正确。我可以真正信任她。所以不是那么多，我的意思是，我显然告诉她，因为她是其中的一部分。我必须像清理她在这里的网球和高尔夫时间表，这样她才能像，你知道，收拾行李和我一起搬家。但是的，她喜欢很多东西。她喜欢，她喜欢像《漫长的过程》。她更喜欢那种电影。
Yeah, yeah. But she loved this movie, this fantasy movie, this school for good and evil. She really loved it. I can't wait to see it. She's a big golfer. She's a big golfer. We need to double back to that. She's a big golfer and a really big tennis player.
是的，是的。但她喜欢这部电影，这部奇幻电影，《善恶学校》。她真的很喜欢它。我迫不及待想看它。她是个高尔夫球手。她是个高尔夫球手。我们需要回到那个话题。她是个高尔夫球手，还是个非常棒的网球运动员。
She's super athletic. She's going to be 70 next year, but she plays with 30 year olds. I mean, she's, she hikes every morning at 5am, 3 miles every morning with six dogs. She takes my dogs and her dogs. Wow. And then soon she walks 18 holes and then she plays tennis. No golf, no tennis for you? I only play golf with her and usually just on Mother's Day and I, but I love tennis.
她超级运动。她明年就70岁了，但她和30岁的人一起玩。我的意思是，她，她每天早上5点徒步，每天早上3英里，带着六只狗。她带着我的狗和她的狗。哇。然后很快她走18个洞，然后她打网球。不打高尔夫，不打网球？我只和她打高尔夫，通常只在母亲节，而且我，但我喜欢网球。
But tennis is like a later sport that I just learned because I had to find something for cardio because I couldn't really run anymore. And so I found tennis and I was like, this is great cardio and I enjoy it. Tennis is great. What about the pickle ball? We play a lot of golf. Jason and I play a lot of golf. No, not pickle ball. No pickle ball.
但网球是像我后来才学的运动，因为我必须找点有氧运动，因为我不能再跑步了。所以我发现了网球，我当时就像，这是很好的有氧运动，我很享受。网球很棒。那匹克球呢？我们打很多高尔夫。杰森和我打很多高尔夫。不，不是匹克球。没有匹克球。
No, I mean, isn't that like what bowl people play? Yes, I think so. It's sweeping the nation just because it's easy. It's really sweeping things. Americans really love to fucking glom on this. Do you guys play pickle ball? I have played, Sean's got a pickle ball court and a toilet right in the middle of the court. I'm up for pickle ball.
不，我的意思是，那不是像碗球人玩的东西吗？是的，我想是这样。它正在席卷全国，因为它很容易。它真的席卷了一切。美国人真的很喜欢他妈的迷上这个。你们打匹克球吗？我打过，肖恩有一个匹克球场，球场中间还有一个马桶。我愿意打匹克球。
I would love to learn. I played before, I've played pickle ball before. It ruins your tennis game. I don't advise it if you like tennis because it engages the wrist too much. I like ping pong. I used to play paddle a lot. Anybody like ping pong? Oh, I love ping pong.
我很乐意学习。我以前打过，我以前打过匹克球。它会毁了你的网球水平。如果你喜欢网球，我不建议这样做，因为它对手腕的参与太多了。我喜欢乒乓球。我以前经常打板球。有人喜欢乒乓球吗？哦，我喜欢乒乓球。
I have a ping pong table in my backyard. Are you trying to just bring up stuff that you don't have to move at all? Yeah. Just my upper body. Xbox. What about that? I play that. TV.
我的后院有一个乒乓球桌。你是在试图提出一些你根本不需要动的东西吗？是的。只是我的上半身。Xbox。那个怎么样？我玩那个。电视。
I like watching TV. Now, you seem like such a brave person. What scares the hell out of you? What are you most afraid of? What's like you cook the night? I have a great question. She does seem like a very brave person. Oh, she's nice.
我喜欢看电视。现在，你看起来是个非常勇敢的人。什么东西会把你吓个半死？你最怕什么？你晚上会做饭吗？我有个很棒的问题。她看起来确实是个非常勇敢的人。哦，她人很好。
But it earned bravery, though. It's not fair. I kind of threw up in my mouth a little bit there. I mean, moving when you're 19, you can't speak English. You're making that. Yeah. I mean, a lot of that when I think back and now that I have kids, I'm like, God, it was just, I feel like, you know, if I didn't come out of the circumstances that I did,
但那是赢得的勇敢。这不公平。我刚才差点吐了。我是说，19岁时搬家，你还不会说英语。你做到了。是的。我是说，当我回想起来，现在我有了孩子，我就想，天哪，那真是，我觉得，你知道，如果我不是从我那样的环境中走出来的，
no, my mom would have never done anything like that. And I don't think I would have done anything like that. But I came out of very complicated circumstances. You know, I didn't really, there wasn't a lot of choice. It was like swim or drown. Like what are you going to do staying? Yeah, you're tough, though. You seem very, you're very tough.
不，我妈妈永远不会做那样的事。我也不认为我会做那样的事。但我从非常复杂的情况下走出来。你知道，我真的没有，没有太多选择。就像要么游泳，要么淹死。你留下来能做什么？是的，但你很坚强。你看起来非常，你非常坚强。
Like you have this, you can kind of see it. It's kind of resolved, this inner resolve that come, for me anyway, I've felt like it's always shone through. And you see him. I'm like, oh yeah, yeah. She's on top of her shit. She's very tough. But like, don't talk to her.
就像你有这种，你可以看出来。这是一种决心，这种内在的决心，对我来说，我觉得它总是显露出来。你看着他。我就想，哦，是的，是的。她掌控着一切。她非常坚强。但是，别跟她说话。
Well, yeah. What about like bees? Cause like bees, bees will turn me into somebody I don't want to be seen. I think I've seen you like scream like a girl. I think I have. Yeah. And I'll just run. I'll just, I'll just disappear like with like a rocket flare, like a cartoon character.
嗯，是的。那蜜蜂呢？因为蜜蜂，蜜蜂会把我变成一个我不想被看到的样子。我想我见过你像个女孩一样尖叫。我想我见过。是的。我会直接跑掉。我会，我会像火箭弹一样消失，就像卡通人物那样。
I tell you, I saw a cockroach yesterday and I did not handle it well. Yeah. I'm not good with those guys. I did not handle it well. I really could not. I didn't know what to do with it. I didn't want to kill it, but I also didn't want it to live. I was really, I was very, really torn.
我告诉你，我昨天看到一只蟑螂，我处理得一点也不好。是的。我不擅长对付那些家伙。我处理得不好。我真的做不到。我不知道该拿它怎么办。我不想杀死它，但我也不想让它活着。我真的很，我非常，真的很纠结。
And then I just, the idea of stepping on it. Oh, I couldn't. It was like. What did you do then? I made somebody else do it. Yeah. You called somebody in and did you, did you, did you instruct them not to kill it? No, I was with a number of people.
然后我只是，想到要踩死它。哦，我做不到。就像是。那你做了什么？我让别人去做了。是的。你叫了别人进来，然后你，你，你指示他们不要杀死它吗？不，我和几个人在一起。
No, this was one lady was really brave. She just, she stepped on it. I was like, I'm going to get my shoe off and just did it. I was very grateful. Yes. Is there anything, is there anything within sort of what you, the realm and the, you know, the bigger scope of what you do. So again, as a sort of, as an actor or a producer, a writer, director, whatever, is there anything
不，这位女士真的很勇敢。她只是，她踩了上去。我就想，我要脱掉我的鞋子，然后就做了。我非常感激。是的。在你所做的领域和更广阔的范围内，有什么，有什么，你知道，作为演员、制片人、编剧、导演，无论什么，有什么
that you can think of that you think that seems scary for me to do? Would you dance or sing? I mean, I would dance. I would love to dance. I don't know. I don't think I would sing. I'm a terrible singer. Me too.
你能想到的，你觉得对我来说很可怕的事情吗？你会跳舞或唱歌吗？我是说，我会跳舞。我很乐意跳舞。我不知道。我不认为我会唱歌。我是个糟糕的歌手。我也是。
Yeah. And I'm very uncomfortable singing. Like I break out in hives. That's why Jason Reitman always makes me sing in his movies because it's, he just loves torturing me. But I don't know. I mean, listen, I was really, I was really worried, scared. I was scared of doing Mike and Kelly. I really, I, you know, that's, it's one of those things where you're like hoping for
是的。而且我唱歌时非常不舒服。我会起荨麻疹。这就是为什么杰森·雷特曼总是让我在他的电影里唱歌，因为他就是喜欢折磨我。但我不知道。我是说，听着，我真的很，我真的很担心，害怕。我害怕演《梅根和凯利》。我真的，你知道，那是那种你希望
the best and you try and do as much work as possible, but there's no guarantee, right? And it's like, you go, you're like four or five weeks in and you still don't sound like her. And I did the first round of prosthetics and I looked like Glenn Close. Like it was weird. Like I was like, I don't know if this is going to work out. And so you feel like, you kind of feel like you're out on a limb and you're without a neck.
最好的结果，你尝试尽可能多地工作，但没有保证，对吧？就像，你进行了四五周，你听起来还是不像她。我做了第一轮假体，我看起来像格伦·克洛斯。这很奇怪。我就想，我不知道这是否会成功。所以你感觉，你感觉自己孤立无援，没有退路。
This can definitely go very wrong. Like I definitely felt that. How about when in Prometheus, when you just lit some guy up on fire, that was like, you had like a fire machine and the guy was standing, was it a fire machine? Whatever it's called. I didn't really do that. Oh, you didn't get a fire gun. You had like a fire.
这绝对会出大问题。我确实有这种感觉。在《普罗米修斯》里，当你把某个人点着火时，那是，你有一个喷火器，那个人站在那里，那是喷火器吗？不管它叫什么。我并没有真的那样做。哦，你没有拿到喷火枪。你有一个像火一样的。
You know, they actually, that one did, that did light up minus like there was nobody in front of me, but it did light up. I think they did one where it kind of lights up a little bit. And that was pretty bad. Oh, so that wasn't you just like blowing them to bits like that, lighting them on fire? No, they added that later. Oh, wow. I'm so sorry, Shirley.
你知道，他们实际上，那个确实点着了，减去，我面前没有人，但它确实点着了。我想他们做了一个它会稍微亮一点的。那真的很糟糕。哦，所以那不是你只是把他们炸成碎片，把他们点着火？不，那是他们后来加进去的。哦，哇。我很抱歉，雪莉。
Holy f***ing good. I love that movie so much. You do? That's so sweet. Oh my God. Welcome to Fan Fest. I love that you go between Meg and Kelly and that. I've seen Prometheus like 10 times.
该死的太棒了。我太喜欢那部电影了。你喜欢？那太贴心了。天哪。欢迎来到粉丝节。我喜欢你在《梅根和凯利》和那部电影之间切换。我看了《普罗米修斯》大概10遍。
I didn't love it. And you know what's wild? I mean, that Fassbender is pretty amazing. I did a deep dive on YouTube about it because the engineer, I don't know, you're never mind. These guys are going to fall asleep and finish it. No, we want to hear it so bad. Let's have it.
我不太喜欢它。你知道最疯狂的是什么吗？我是说，法斯宾德太棒了。我在YouTube上深入研究过它，因为工程师，我不知道，你，别介意。这些家伙会睡着并把它看完的。不，我们太想听了。说吧。
I want to know. I heard that he was diving on YouTube before. I don't know if this is true or not because Ridley Scott had, I don't know if it's true, but I heard that he had this original script that explained kind of the whole, they gave this engineer, this dialogue that explained the whole movie, but he cut it, which was that in the Bible, when Jesus was in there for however many years, because you know, the Bible cuts from when he was a kid to 30, that these engineers, these aliens came, picked them up, brought them to their planet, taught them how they should teach humanity, brought
我想知道。我听说他在YouTube上潜水之前。我不知道这是不是真的，因为雷德利·斯科特有，我不知道是不是真的，但我听说他有一个原始剧本，解释了整个，他们给了这个工程师，这段对话解释了整部电影，但他剪掉了，那就是在圣经里，当耶稣在里面待了多少年时，因为你知道，圣经从他小时候跳到了30岁，这些工程师，这些外星人来了，接走了他，带到了他们的星球，教他应该如何教导人类，带
them back. And then that's what he tried to do, but they failed. And that's why these aliens want to come back and wipe it out because it's gotten so bad. And you heard this where? What? Online, somewhere. Wow. I can't verify that for you.
他们回来。然后这就是他试图做的，但他们失败了。这就是为什么这些外星人想回来消灭它，因为它变得太糟糕了。你在哪里听到的？什么？网上，某个地方。哇。我无法为你核实这一点。
That's really interesting. It's fascinating, isn't it? I fucking... And if it's not true, it's a good idea. That's a great idea. The world is round too, Sean. It's round. It's where?
那真的很有趣。很迷人，不是吗？我他妈的……如果这不是真的，那也是个好主意。那是个好主意。地球也是圆的，肖恩。它是圆的。在哪里？
But anyway. I think some listeners right now are, like, touching themselves. Like, you know, people really appreciate that kind of knowledge. Thank you. They're really touching themselves, like, am I fucking here? Is this... Is this actually... Did I just pass out?
但无论如何。我想现在有些听众，就像，在自慰。你知道，人们真的很欣赏那种知识。谢谢。他们真的在自慰，就像，我他妈的在这里吗？这是……这是真的吗……我刚才晕倒了吗？
What am I... Did I... Yeah. I didn't know if you knew... If you heard that, if that was true... No, I did not. No, you know why? Because she doesn't spend her time on Reddit with you and Scotty.
我在……我……是的。我不知道你是否知道……如果你听过那个，如果那是真的……不，我不知道。不，你知道为什么吗？因为她不花时间在Reddit上和你还有斯科蒂一起。
Going fucking putting in Prometheus fucking theories. Chat rooms. Scotty, we should get to bed. It's 4 a.m. Yeah, but look at this thread. Look at this fucking thread. Fucking fuck, man. It's bad.
去他妈的发布《普罗米修斯》他妈的理论。聊天室。斯科蒂，我们该睡觉了。现在是凌晨4点。是的，但看看这个帖子。看看这个他妈的帖子。他妈的，伙计。太糟糕了。
That stuff is fascinating to me. I know, Angel. I know. All right. All right. Charlize, you're the greatest. Yeah. You're the best ever.
那些东西对我来说很迷人。我知道，安吉尔。我知道。好了。好了。查理兹，你是最棒的。是的。你是史上最好的。
Guys, I really love this show. Congratulations. We love you. I listen to it all the time when I start waiting to pick my kids up. It's a joy to listen to you guys. You're really funny. Thank you. Thanks for having me.
伙计们，我真的很喜欢这个节目。恭喜。我们爱你。我总是听它，当我开始等着接我的孩子时。听你们的节目是一种乐趣。你们真的很幽默。谢谢。谢谢你们邀请我。
Yeah. And thank you for having me. I guess you ran out of people. Yeah. Every time I would listen to it, I thought, yeah. How dare you? Yeah. We're on the tease.
是的。也谢谢你们邀请我。我猜你们没人可找了。是的。每次我听的时候，我都想，是的。你怎么敢？是的。我们在逗你。
Between Jason and Will, between both of you, I could make... It's Will, but that's... Will, that's how we say it in Afrikaans. I was like, wow. I'm like, you guys must have really cleared your list. Even you, Sean, I know you too. Like, what the fuck happened? Can I tell you something?
在杰森和威尔之间，你们两个之间，我可以做……是威尔，但那是……威尔，这就是我们在南非语中的说法。我就想，哇。我就想，你们一定真的清空了你们的名单。甚至是你，肖恩，我也认识你。就像，到底发生了什么？我能告诉你一件事吗？
What is it? Season 17? No, can I tell you something right now? You've been on my list since day one. And obviously, Jason, you were on Jason's list as well. Yeah. And I was like, no, I get her. So, Will is the one that we...
是什么？第17季？不，我现在能告诉你一件事吗？你从第一天起就在我的名单上了。显然，杰森，你也在杰森的名单上。是的。我就想，不，我选她。所以，威尔是我们……
I don't know. I had a different list. And then it just... I don't know. I didn't have a pen. I didn't end up having a pen. Well, thank you for having me, you guys. Yes.
我不知道。我有一个不同的名单。然后它就……我不知道。我没有笔。我最终没有笔。好吧，谢谢你们邀请我。是的。
We love you. Have a great rest of the day. Love you. Right back. You guys too. Thank you for doing this. All right. Bye.
我们爱你。祝你余下的一天过得愉快。爱你。也爱你。你们也是。谢谢你们做这个。好了。再见。
Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye. Bye.
再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。再见。
Bye. Bye. We had great directors. We sure did. The Rusev Bowl. What's the name of the show? Oh, man. Oh my God.
再见。再见。我们有很棒的导演。我们确实有。鲁塞夫碗。节目的名字是什么？哦，伙计。天哪。
It's so... Should we come over? We should come over. We'll go over to Shawn's house. We'll watch some rest of development. And then you come over to one of our houses. We'll watch Will and Grace together. We'll watch Will and Grace.
太……我们要过去吗？我们应该过去。我们要去肖恩家。我们要看一些《发展受阻》。然后你来我们其中一个人的家里。我们一起看《威尔和格蕾丝》。我们要看《威尔和格蕾丝》。
That sounds like a fun... We'll make a new podcast out of it. Yeah. You know, a little watch through. And we'll sign it. We'll sign the contract that we each... We're all gonna watch it. And that contract will be binding.
听起来很有趣……我们要从中制作一个新的播客。是的。你知道，一个小小的观看过程。我们要签署。我们要签署合同，我们每个人……我们都要看它。那个合同将具有约束力。
Binding. You guys, I fucking, I was crying, laughing so hard, good God. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast. Smart. Blast.
约束力。你们，我他妈的，我笑得哭了，天哪。聪明。爆炸。聪明。爆炸。聪明。爆炸。
Smart. Blast. SmartList is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf and Bennett Barbaco. Smart. Blast. Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus
聪明。爆炸。SmartList是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴巴科100%有机且手工制作的。聪明。爆炸。我们的下一集将在下周发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅Wondry Plus提前且无广告收听
in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在苹果播客或Wondry应用程序中。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。